[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver pour le temps fort de la
semaine au sénat les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
ça commence dans une heure à 15 heures
précises une heure et une quinzaine de
questions pour interpeller le
gouvernement mais avant cela on va
parler de la reprise de l'école nouveau
protocole sanitaire et retour
obligatoire pour tous les élèves à
partir du 22 juin dans quelles
conditions et pour quels bénéfices c'est
l'objet de notre débat dont cinq minutes
on va aussi tenter d'y voir clair sur le
prof bashing et sur le procès fait aux
profs décrocheurs va-t-il falloir
travailler plus pour relancer l'économie
dans cette phase de déconfinement chacun
y va de ses propositions
hier c'est le groupe ait l'air au sénat
qui a rendu public son plan
au programme relocalisation et fiscalité
bleu blanc rouge
notre face à face à 14h30 et puis le
rendez vous à ne pas manquer c'est bien
sûr les questions d'actu à 15h la
sécurité premier sujet de ces questions
puisque la droite notamment prévoit
plusieurs interpellations du
gouvernement sur les forces de l'ordre
ont encore la flambée des violences à
dijon on va vous faire vivre tout ça
avec alexandre poussard salle des
conférences
et surtout n'hésitez pas à réagir et à
commenter cette émission avec le hashtag
qu un jeu
et on vient de le voir à l'instant on va
commencer cette émission en rejoignant
alexandre poussard salle des conférences
alexandre bonjour ça va être le grand
oral de christophe castaner cette séance
de questions d'actualité
bonjour tam effectivement plusieurs
questions sur le thème de la sécurité et
notamment sur cette flambée des
violences à dijon alors que le calme est
revenu aujourd'hui dans la capitale
bourguignonne
mais après des nuits de violences et
d'affrontements entre la communauté de
tchétchènes et les habitants du quartier
des grésillés le retard de
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
dans cette affaire sera sans doute
pointé du doigt par les sénateurs mais
plus globalement les parlementaires vont
aborder la question des relations entre
le gouvernement et les forces de l'ordre
sur fond de débat autour des violences
policières et du racisme noter que la
majorité de droite ici au sénat défend
bec et ongles
l'institution policière le deuxième axe
de cette séance de questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
eh bien ils concernent l'emploi des
jeunes en danger durant cette crise
économique puisque à la rentrée de
septembre sept cent mille jeunes vont
entrer sur le marché du travail et il
pourrait y avoir beaucoup de chômeurs
alors actuellement il ya un débat sur
les solutions à mettre en oeuvre
faut-il une prime à l'embauché des
jeunes ou une baisse de charges sur
leurs contrats le gouvernement doit
trancher
voilà tam pour le programme de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre on vous
retrouve bien sûr tout au long de cette
émission mais d'abord et bien on va
passer à notre débat notre débat sur
l'école la reprise est fixée au 22 juin
fin du volontariat pour les élèves et
pour les enseignants c'est ce qu'a
déclaré emmanuel macron dimanche alors
que le nouveau protocole sanitaire doit
être rendu public aujourd'hui et que les
distances entre élèves vont pouvoir être
réduite on parle de cette nouvelle
rentrée dans un instant mais d'abord
retour sur le contexte et la polémique
qui enfle les profs décrocheurs et le
mouvement de profs bashing alizés
boissin matin
on a plus de partage d'écran en finir
avec l'enseignement à distance à partir
de lundi les collégiens et les primaires
devront obligatoirement retourner à
l'école même devoir pour les professeurs
l'occasion peut être de freiner la
polémique sur l'absentéisme du corps
enseignant pendant le confinement
d'après le ministère de l'éducation
nationale quarante mille professeurs
auraient décroché et ne répondre ni
aucun travail pendant la période
cela représente 5 % de la profession des
chiffres monté en épingle dans certains
reportages qui heurte les syndicats
quand je vois ça bien sûr moi je suis
ulcérée parce que je vois qu'on porte
atteinte à toute la réputation d'une
profession cette polémique est
particulièrement malvenu et ne reconnaît
pas vraiment la réalité de l'engagement
extraordinaire qui était celui des
personnels enseignants pendant cette
période et avec le déconfinement la
polémique ne s'éteint pas
quatre professeurs sur 10 n'était pas en
classe lors de la reprise en mai pour
les syndicats la reprise partielle
s'explique d'abord par des contraintes
sanitaires
actuellement on demande quasiment aux
enseignants de
les contres un protocole qui est fixé
par leur ministère pour pouvoir
accueillir tout
tous les élèves c'est pas possible du
côté du gouvernement on tente d'apaiser
le débat là dessus je veux vraiment
qu'on arrête avec le prof bashing
les enseignants ont été extrêmement
mobilisés pendant le confinement et ce
n'était pas facile parfois depuis chez
eux quand eux-mêmes avaient des enfants
chez eux avec l'ordinateur personnel et
parfois des équipements qui était pas
toujours présent pour faire le lien avec
les élèves
il y en a qui ont vraiment mais fait
preuve d'une inventivité exceptionnelle
pour réussir à toucher des élèves
éloignés ou ou décrocheurs comme ceux
qu'on évoquait à partir de lundi toute
absence sans motif valable sera passible
de sanctions et sur ce débat sur l'école
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir jacques
grosperrin bonjour vous êtes sénateur à
l'ère du doubs vice président de la
commission de la culture et de
l'éducation également sur ce plateau
sylvie robert bonjour vous êtes
sénatrice ps d'ille-et-vilaine vice
présidente de la commission de la
culture et de l'éducation également avec
nous en visioconférence j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir jean rémy girard vous êtes
président du syndicat national des
lycées et collèges snalc merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous et gérard paumier c'est
le point de vue est bien des parents
vous êtes président de la fédération des
parents d'élèves de l'enseignement
public
la pep première question pour vous
sylvie robert les enseignants ils ont
été encensée pendant une partie du
confinement les voies la cible de
critiques pour vous que s'est il passé
écoutez je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
passé mais je trouve assez insupportable
que on alimente une polémique alors
qu'on devrait au contraire salué les 95%
c'est le chiffre qui est annoncé un
d'enseignants qui ont effectivement non
seulement joué le jeu mais agi avec
beaucoup de réactivité beaucoup
d'inventivité et qui sur les questions
du numérique et on le dit souvent à la
commission qui a une vraie question sur
la formation des enseignants numérique
ont réagi avec vraiment énormément de
professionnels il avec souvent leur dos
un terreau perd absolument dans des
endroits où on ne sait pas
obligatoirement si si ça passe donc je
trouve ça assez insupportables voire
même très indigne et j'aimerais que
on se dise que les 5% soit disant il ya
peut-être aussi des enseignants qui sont
tombés malades qui ont été sans en
parler un peu atteint par cette période
de confinement donc non je crois que il
faut arrêter vraiment l'a77 prof bashing
comme on dit on va essayer de voir ce
qu'il ya derrière ces chiffres mais il
est vrai qu'il y a eu des tribunes assez
violente à l'égard des enseignants par
exemple cet article de l'opinion qui dit
eh bien qu'ils parlent de cette moitié
des enseignants n'ayant pas repris le
chemin de l'école et dont une part non
négligeable serait à ranger dans la
catégorie des tire-au-flanc ce sont des
mots extrêmement durs
jacques grosperrin qu'est ce que vous en
pensez oui c'est dur et c'est sa ligne
aussi moi je rejoins ma collègue sylvie
robert je trouve que justement les
enseignants ils ont exemplaire vous
savez on sortait d'une crise du gilet
jaune
on sortait d'un moment difficile où
chacun on parlait de réforme des
retraites et en peu de temps
en peu de temps ils sont mobilisés vous
imaginez qu'on a eu on a annoncé le
confinement donc un jeudi ou vendredi le
lundi c'était déjà prêts à pouvoir
prendre en charge leurs élèves
je veux que c'est indigne est
véritablement moi je vois ce qui s'est
fait il ya eu de l'allant tivité mais il
ya aussi eu du courage il ya eu aussi
des enseignants qui se sont déplacés
pour voir des élèves qui étaient loin
justement de l'anciennement je crois
qu'il faut arrêter tout cela on a la
chance d'avoir une confession et 5% déjà
un les 5 % on s'est pas véritablement si
l'on va exactement les et puis et puis 2
je crois que la population princesse
dans tous les métiers en moins d'années
peut avoir ce genre de choses mais je
crois qu'il faut être plutôt solidaires
dans dans ce type de moment parce que je
crois qu'ils ont été vraiment exemplaire
on le voit ya donc un consensus là
dessus sur ce plateau qu'en pensent les
parents d'élèves l'apep gérard paumier
il ya aussi tout de même des choses à
dire lors de ce confinement on a vu
aussi des lettres de parents d'élèves se
plaignant d'un cert du coût de certains
enseignants oui bien sûr de toute façon
ce qu'il faut dire poser au pea nabeul
c'est que nous à l'appel nous ne sommes
pas dans la polémique il donc en fait
nous essayons de
devant les choses telles qu'elles sont
deux ou trois points de vue et en tout
cas de notre angle de vue et bien
effectivement cette période de
continuité pédagogique et ensuite de
santé du säntis du confinement dix on a
montré que globalement je dirais il ya
eu une bonne volonté de la part de tous
doit pas de la communauté dans son
ensemble disons de d'agir face à cette
situation très particulière
nous l'appelons une situation
extraordinaire et par rapport à cette
situation extraordinaire c'est vrai
qu'il n'y peut être très facile de jeter
l'opprobe la critique et non nous ne
sommes pas dans cette optique bien
bien entendu nous avons constaté nous
avons pu constater quelques fois des
décalages entre eux quelquefois ce qui
était annoncé
et puis en fait ce qu'on constatait par
exemple si pour la vison la grande
majorité des cas les choses se passaient
très bien on a pu constater que
quelquefois justement il y avait un un
surcroît d'activité que quelquefois
certains certaines familles proprement
dite était assommé d'exercice et tandis
que d'autres pas du tout donc on a vu où
deux extrêmes mais ça ça nous nous ne
nous servons pas de ça pour jeter
l'opprobre n'est pas jeter l'opprobre
sur les enseignants jean rémy girard
néanmoins vous entendez cette critique
le fait que c'est bien cette main de
confinement a aussi mis en avant est
bien le fait qu'il y avait des preuves
qu'ils travaillent plus que dos des
enseignants remarquable d'autres sites
qui n'ont pas donné de nouvelles
mais ce qui nous intéresse au snalc
c'est de voir que vous êtes en train de
dire c'est vrai pour à peu près
n'importe quelle profession dans
n'importe quelle profession il ya des
gens qui travaillent un peu plus que
d'autres
il ya des gens qui on a peut-être un peu
perdus des radars mais le phénomène
absolument incroyable alors même que
tout le monde a reconnu l'engagement des
personnels de l'éducation nationale
c'est qu'on s'est retrouvé dans seul ou
à taper uniquement sur les profs
il ya sûrement des absents dans à peu
près tous les métiers de la terre
en france mais on s'est dit très
impatient d'être au meilleur dans tous
les métiers alors ces fameux 5%
voilà puisqu'on en parle ces fameux 5 %
qui sont d'ailleurs pas des chiffres
j'allais dire officielle dans le sens où
ils auraient été recensés avec avec tout
le travail statistique nécessaire
ces fameux 5 % 4 à 5% intègre les arrêts
maladie pour raisons valables intègre
les absences personnel ou raison valable
donc en fait si l'on parle de
décrocheurs qui est un mot coastal que
nous n'utilisons pas pour les
enseignants c'est des décrocheurs ça
peut être des élèves c'est un phénomène
pédagogique c'est un phénomène scolaire
mais ça ne s'applique pas à des
professionnels on parle pas de policiers
décrocheurs pompiers décrocheurs donc ya
pas de raison par les d'enseignants
décrocheurs voilà donc on constate qu'il
ya une infime minorité potentiellement
d'enseignants qui serait peut-être passé
sous le radar encore qu' ils ont
peut-être même des raisons valables là
dessus quelqu'un qui avait pas de
connexion internet hors du confinement
passé à peu près logique qu'ils aient eu
du mal à proposer quoi que ce soit dont
on a en fait oui on va parler
effectivement de ces statistiques
puisque on a quelques chiffres à on va
regarder les statistiques de l'éducation
nationale il ya eu 55 % des professeurs
qui étaient en présentiel à l'école
primaire
c'était des chiffres début juin 60% des
enseignants présents au collège et vous
dites la plupart des autres ont assuré
l'enseignement en distance yale car
certes on estime qu'il ya eu 5 % des
enseignants soit quarante mille profs
qui ont manqué à l'appel
mais il y avait aussi un certain nombre
de raisons derrière cela il ya les
contraintes sanitaires
il y à la question de la garde des
enfants ou encore bien sûr comme dans
tous les métiers il ya aussi la question
de la vulnérabilité physique du coup et
bien jacques grosperrin
quand on parle de profs décrocheurs
c'est une erreur
monsieur moi je crois qu'il faut dire
plutôt prof accrocheurs ils sont
accrochés à leur métier ils sont
accrochés à leurs élèves à leur
profession et puis vous avez raison de
le dire il ya des situations qui sont
tellement différentes moi j'ai vu des
enseignants un moment donné deux
capables de faire cours en présentiel
rentrer chez eux et faire courant
distant ciel je crois que c'est on l'a
dit tout à l'heure c'est indigne
ils ont fait leur travail ils l'ont fait
très bien ils sont allés rechercher des
enfants qui c'était un petit peu éloigné
de la scolarité et de l'enseignement
je crois qu'il faut le rendre hommage
aujourd'hui ce qui est compliqué aussi
pour les enseignants notamment dans
cette phase de déconfinement c'est que
l'école est restée enfin la présence à
l'école est restée sur la base du
volontariat
est ce que pour vous c'était une erreur
sylvie robert volontariat de la part des
enseignants et de la part des élèves non
il faut quand même remettre les choses à
leur place c'est à dire que au moment où
on a parlé de reprise de l'école seti
sur la base d'un protocole sanitaire
extrêmement drastiques et c'était de mon
point de vue sûrement nécessaires pour
faire en sorte que la confiance revienne
c'est à dire souvenez vous on était
quand même encore dans la peur de du
déconfinement et donc il fallait un
moment faire ça étape par étape
après on va passer à une autre étape on
va en parler m'en parler de lundi
prochain même de joie mais je ne pense
pas parce que comme disait mon collègue
il y à des enseignants qui ont assuré le
présentiel et le distant ciel c'est à
dire qu' il ne faut pas seulement se
baser sur la base du pourcentage de ceux
qui étaient présents dans l'est dans les
établissements ils ont aussi assuré le
distance yale et ils sont allés et je
peux le confirmer
eux-mêmes dans des familles pour voir ma
les enfants qui n'avaient pas réussi à
accrocher justement donc je ne sais pas
bien compliqué attention à ce qu'on dit
ans gérard paumier est ce que ces
critiques ne reflète pas aussi bien la
situation des parents les parents qui
ont de moins en moins de patience face à
cette situation compliquée pour tout le
monde et à qui on réclame aussi d'être
de plus en plus actif dans l'entreprise
dans la reprise du travail
oui c'est certain mais avant tout je
voudrais dire que effectivement la
majorité la grande majorité des
enseignants est un remercié mais tout
autant que l'ensemble de la communauté
c'est à dire je veux noté je veux parler
des familles et aussi des élèves en
début de confinement il est arrivé
j'ai eu plusieurs exemples que des
élèves et professeurs avec certains
outils numériques
donc je dis oui code là où ça a pu
marcher c'est parce qu'il ya une
cohésion et qu'en fait on s'est rendu
compte que et c'était peut-être en
certains lieux croiser des gens des
barrières et jean coin que le plus
important c'est que nous puissions tirer
de cette période extraordinaire je me
rappelle un certain nombre
d'enseignements pour l'avenir
jean rémy girard qu'est ce que vous
pensez tout de même de ce procès qui
commence à vous est fait car certes il
sur ce plateau c'est assez consensuel il
n'y a pas de critiques sévères des
enseignants mais on les voit ses
critiques qu'il ya eu des enseignants
même ses propos rapportés d'un ministre
qui dit si les salariés de la grande
distribution avait été aussi courageux
que l'éducation nationale les français
n'aurait rien eu à manger qu'est ce que
ça vous inspire ce début de procès qui
vous est fait par certains pas pour tout
le monde mais par certains
vu ce qu'on nous a dit au début du
confinement avec beaucoup de retours
probablement des mêmes médias d'ailleurs
dix ans les parents sont surchargés les
élèves sont surchargés on en donne trop
a priori si la grande distribution avait
fait comme nous tout le monde aurait eu
une indigestion
donc voilà un moment je crois que on est
dans une certaine polémique de personnes
qui sont un mal informés et 2 qui ont de
toute façon un a priori d'enlever sur
notre profession et j'ai envie de dire
on ne changera pas leur avis donc nous
on arrête de se battre contre des
moulins à vent
nous ce que l'on fait c'est qu'on
rétabli la vérité la vérité des chiffres
la vérité de l'engagement je tiens à
dire à gérard commis ici que oui nous on
a tout à fait constater l'extrême bonne
volonté des parents et des élèves dans
cette situation on a réussi à travailler
ensemble pour quelque chose qui n'était
pas prévu et sur lequel personne n'était
présent ni les parents ni les élèves ni
les enseignants à faire ce que ce que
l'on a fait collectivement et et ça a
été exceptionnel faut quand même se
rappeler que le premier employeur de
france
du jour au lendemain a demandé à 850
mille personnes de se mettre en
télétravail sur son matériel personnel
voilà c'est ce qui s'est passé et les
850 mille personnes peut-être à aller
voilà 2000 près quoi se sont mises au
télétravail sur leur matériel personnel
leur connexion leur ordinateur etc
c'est exceptionnel effectivement qu'on
en soit arrivé on soit arrivé à réussir
ça ensemble et je pense peut
effectivement certains journalistes
parce que la plupart des journalistes
éducation le 10 mars ancien retrouve
dans ces tribunes
voilà de vrais voeux devrait nous
remercier et devrait nous remercier tous
collectivement de ce qu'on a fait alors
en tout cas maintenant et bien
normalement le télétravail c'est terminé
pour le à partir du 22 juin l'objectif
bien c'est bien de remettre tous les
enfants à l'école à 100% et sans doute
de permettre à leurs parents de
retrouver le chemin du travail ça va
être un sacré challenge pour les écoles
écoutez là dessus bien le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
hier lors de la séance des questions
d'actualité de l'assemblée cette
confiance elle est là aujourd'hui elle
est là parce que désormais les parents
ont confiance dans le fait d'envoyer les
enfants à l'école et l'ensemble de
l'institution a confiance en elle même
est donc aujourd'hui nous pouvons avoir
un nouveau protocole sanitaire allégé
tout simplement parce que collectivement
nous tous les français nous avons pu
faire progresser le pays
s'agissant du virus et nous avons
aujourd'hui des conditions qui nous
permette d'aller de l'avant
cet allégement du protocole sanitaire il
se traduit par plusieurs mesures mais la
principale c'est évidemment l'allègement
des conditions distanciation physique
cet allégement nous permet de pouvoir
accueillir tous les élèves
nous travaillons d'ailleurs avec les
organisations représentatifs et en lien
avec le ministère de la santé pour que
ce protocole sanitaire soit publié ce
protocole sanitaire va donc nous
permettre d'avoir le retour de tous les
enfants à l'école et au collège et aussi
d'ouvrir davantage les lycées de france
puisque nous sommes en zone verte
hormis en guyane et à mayotte et c'est
évidemment une très bonne nouvelle je
suis certain que désormais la
représentation nationale sera unanime
pour célébrer ce début retour à la
normale jacques grosperrin c'est une
très bonne nouvelle la reprise pour le
22 juin mais sommes nous prêts oui c'est
une bonne nouvelle parce qu'il faut
quand même pas oublier que au départ
c'était prévu pour 15 jours le
confinement
il a duré près de trois mois on ne peut
pas accepter que des enfants ne retourne
pas à l'école avant
reprise de septembre maintenant moi je
crois à la sincérité certainement du
ministre mais on sort bien avec la
patate chaude lui a été lancé parce
qu'en réalité lorsque vous entendez elle
a été lancé dimanche par m annuellement
exactement dimanche par emmanuel macron
qui dit on va rouvrir les écoles les
écoles le 22
sauf qu'à un moment donné lorsque vous
discutez avec les directeurs d'école
avec les principaux de collèges et avec
les maires ils vous disent on ne sait
pas faire
s'il faut mettre un mètre de distance
physique entre les élèves etc
ils ont regardé dans leur salle de
classe ils peuvent accueillir 23 24
élèves ils pourront pas accueillir 27 28
et c'est donc un moment donné je crois
qu'il faut être réaliste il ya une vraie
difficulté par rapport à ça c'est un
symbole fort il faut que les enfants
retournent à l'école mais il était aussi
le dispositif deux aces de c'est
peut-être à améliorer accompagner
financièrement pour en faire en sorte
que l'on puisse tous est acceptée mais
la difficulté de les mettre en car à ce
moment à la santé je crois que c'est
impossible
sylvie robert c'est un signal politique
un signal politique important mais dans
les faits c'est un petit peu hors sol de
ce qu'a dit le président de la
république dimanche
non non c'était pas harceler moi je
trouve que c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce que je pense qu'il fallait que
tous les enfants retournent à l'école
après pour moi il ya deux problèmes il
ya un problème de fond est un poème de
forme je vais commencer par prennent de
forme qui est la méthode je trouve qu'un
problème de méthode lorsque et ça s'est
passé la première fois sur la premier
protocole sanitaire les enseignants et
les maires parce que c'est quand même et
les autres collectivités découvre un
protocole sanitaire trois jours avant la
reprise mais or le premier souvenez-vous
été très contraignant il faisait 52
pages et ça a été quand même extrêmement
compliqué pour eux aujourd'hui à ma
connaissance je n'ai toujours pas vu le
nouveau protocole allégé n'ont pas
encore à celui de roddick
hier déjà mais pour l'instant voilà
encore et la reprise si je m'abuse et
bien lundi
alors on sait quand même qu'il va y
avoir un mètre de distanciation ça c'est
la question de fond et moi je rejoins
mon collègue
moi j'ai beaucoup de mères qui me disent
que en l'état actuel des locaux c'est
une question tout simplement
d'organisation de l'espace et donc des
questions de physique de
eh bien ils ne pourront pas accueillir
tout le monde donc vous voyez la jeune
nation terminé aussi le ballon avait le
plus à la légère je ne sais pas ce qui
va se passer en termes de désinfection
des locaux
qu'est ce que ça va être plusieurs fois
par jour parce que monsieur disait très
justement il faut remercier la
communauté éducative mais je voudrais
aussi par rapport à cette reprise
progressive qu'on salue les agents
municipaux les maires les élus parce que
c'est eux qui forcément ont dû faire
face à tout cela
donc si vous voulez un moment donné il
ya des injonctions paradoxales alors je
ne sais pas comment ça va se passer
lundi mais je sais que dans un certain
nombre d'écoles et bien tout simplement
parce que ce n'est pas possible
les maires et donc les directeur de
cannes ne vont pas et les nombreuses et
un bail arrivait ne vont pas réussir à
accueillir tout le monde mais disons que
qu'est ce qui va se passer et la
question du brassage je ne sais pas ce
qu'il ya dans le nouveau protocole
donc vous voyez il ya quand même un
certain nombre d'interrogations qui fait
qu'on est à trois joué et que la ja
grand père après le cil ministre moi
j'ai eu la chance de l'avoir au
téléphone parce qu'il ya cette grande
inquiétude de la part de tous les élus
qui me dit qu'à 15h le protocole hadji
serait là et que tout sera fait pour
accueillir tous les élèves
mais je me demande comment tout sera
fait je pense que là une vraie
interrogation vis-à-vis de cela jean
rémy girerd vous partagez vous ces
inquiétudes
est ce que vous vous êtes prêt et puis
aussi à cette question c'est que l'on va
rendre obligatoire l'école et le collège
mais pas le lycée par contre oui alors
il ya plusieurs choses déjà sur le
protocole alléger le snal qui a réussi
par des moyens l'absolu m'en détourner à
se procurer ce matin le projet
provisoire de protocole allégée que
certains chefs d'établissement ou
inspecteur d'éducation nationale avait
reçu
donc on l'a publié sur notre site donc
madame la sénatrice si vous voulez voir
ce qui n'est pas le protocole mais ce
qui ressemble protocole vous pouvez
aller www.slate.fr les aurai la plupart
des informations mais en sachant que
comme le disait le sénateur grosperrin
il y a encore des points 1 point
notamment qui reste à travailler
visiblement qui est le cas où la
distanciation physique n'est pas
possible à respecter les fameux un
maître latéraux qui ça qui ne fonctionne
pas dans beaucoup de salles de salles de
classe et là les mois on attend de voir
comment on va en sortir de ce truc là
parce que nous on a quand même un décret
que quand même pas un petit texte qui
dit que c'est quelque chose
d'obligatoire pour les écoles et pour
les collèges
là je rejoins la sénatrice a volé la
victoire tout à fait une injonction
contradictoire on veut pas dire ça mieux
que vous ne le dites je rejoins la
sénatrice pour dire qu'on a vu un
problème de méthode
nous les organisations syndicales
représentatives on a découvert lundi
matin
le décret mentionnant c'est un maître
latéraux honnêtement le ministère nous
aurait contacté vendredi soir samedi et
c'est en nous disant on compte sortir ça
met immédiatement leur aurait dit
attention ça va poser tel problème tel
problème tel problème est peut-être
qu'on aurait pu sortir autre chose
là on se retrouve un petit peu coincé
pour répondre à la deuxième question sur
le fait que ça reprenne sur les écoles
et des collèges et pas sur les lycées
c'est pour des raisons sanitaires c'est
à dire que visiblement l'état actuel des
connaissances scientifiques
on sait que les lycéens en termes de
propagation du virus ce sont des adultes
alors que visiblement les écoliers et
les collégiens propage beaucoup moins le
virus donc c'est pour ça que dans les
lycées
on reste sur les modalités actuelles
il faut dire aussi et on va le dire que
enfin peut honnêtement que l'année
scolaire dans les lycées elle est finie
tous les conseils de classe ont eu lieu
les élèves ont rendu leurs manuels dans
mon lycée
ils ont dit au revoir aux enseignants
dans le manuel de très clairement et on
leur en veux pas du tout on les comprend
gérard paumier vous qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire un on entend les
difficultés que vont avoir les
établissements scolaires a organisé
cette rentrée le 22
et puis on le sait aussi il ya aussi les
parents qui ont déjà pris leurs
dispositions pour leurs enfants qu'ils
avaient prévu
qu'ils aillent ailleurs qu'il soit gardé
sur cette période et puis cette question
cette crainte toujours du risque
sanitaire
oui bien sûr alors notre position c'est
que le maximum d'enfants devraient
reprendre le chemin mais nous savons
également que d'autres que de nombreux
vraiment ont déjà pris leurs
dispositions et alors là il ne s'agit
pas effectivement de leurs contraindre
par la coercition à reprendre un
processus lent processus de rentrer
physique alors qu'ils ont déjà pris
toutes leurs dispositions puisque
rappelons le c'est l'instruction qui est
obligatoire
donc nous avons eu à faire face à une
situation extraordinaire
il convient d'en tenir compte alors oui
effectivement un certain nombre de
parents ne environ pas leur enfant pour
deux trois semaines de cours mais ton
nous l'essentiel c'est que cette période
là et fournit un minimum d'expérience et
d'expérimentation pour pouvoir aborder
la prochaine rentrée scolaire
qu'est ce qu'il ya à attendre de cette
période sylvie robert il ya un intérêt
pédagogique un intérêt psychologique
quand même à revenir même si c'est
seulement pour 15 jours à l'école avant
les vacances
oui je pense que c'est pour les enfants
et les jeunes puisqu'on parle de
collégiens important même qu'il revienne
15 jours parce que la question
de l'école elle passe par le collectif
elle passe par forcément le lien aussi
physique à leurs camarades qui n'ont pas
vu souvent depuis plusieurs semaines
mais aussi avec l'enseignant et je pense
que c'est très important que que ce
retour de 15 jours soit effectif
et si je pouvais me projeter puisque
monsieur mis un site pour la rentrée de
septembre
j'espère et je souhaite que le ministre
de l'éducation nationale tire les leçons
de ce qui s'est passé à de ce qui se
passe actuellement aussi en termes de
méthode que ce soit propice pour
travailler avec la communauté éducative
mais aussi avec les maires pour
justement envisager la rentrée de
septembre
aujourd'hui ils sont encore dans
l'inconnu nous sommes encore dans
l'inconnu
on ne sait pas dans quelles conditions
la reprise va pouvoir se faire et je
pense vraiment qu'il y a nécessité à
concertée de façon générale l'ensemble
des organisations mais aussi les parents
l'ensemble de la communauté giret et les
maires pour se dire comment allons-nous
faire au mois de septembre
parce que là ça va devenir vraiment
problématique et il faut le faire
maintenant il faut le faire là
maintenant préparer cette rentrée c'est
encore le grand flou pour septembre
jacques grosperrin bien sûr il faudra
déjà supprimé les évaluations parce
qu'on pourra pas accepter que pendant le
premier trimestre trimestre on les
professeurs soient sur les évaluations
il faudra rattraper le temps scolaire
qui n'a pas été là où qui a été
difficile qui a été en distance yen mais
nos ports présentiel crois qu'il faudra
vraiment réfléchi faudra se soit une
période d'à premier trimestre de
remédiation de réapprentissage où il y
aura pas de sanction pas d'évaluation de
une certaine bienveillance parce que je
crois que c'est important et elle
reprises la rentrée scolaire ou la
reprise ou la rentrée scolaire de
septembre sera synonyme de réussite
scolaire puis après on peut enfin pour
terminer ce ne sera plus jamais comme
avant
ça veut dire qu'on peut très bien
imaginer que même en retrait pour
l'école qu'il y aura un moment des
moments présentiel puis des moments
distant ciel de réapprentissage de
renforcement des savoirs de renforcement
des compétences
par la suite il ya aussi eu un grand
sujet d'inquiétude pendant cette période
de confinement eh bien c'est la question
des quartiers
regardez ce que disait bien
l'association france urbaine qui
explique dans les villes où les
quartiers dans lesquels inquiétudes
liées aux risques d' élèves décrocheurs
est très importante le taux de retour à
l'école est inférieure à 5% inférieur à
5% c'est vraiment enfin c'est si peu que
c'est vrai que j'ai dû aurait vérifié
plusieurs fois ce chiffre
jean rémy girard il ya quand même eu un
un énorme décrochage entre les élèves
est vraiment ces inégalités qui ont été
mises en avant sur cette période
bien sûr bien entendu puisque il faut se
rappeler que cette période de
confinement on a il n'y avait pas toutes
façons de bonne solution on a fait ce
qu'on a pu faire de loin mauvais
globalement mais forcément quand on fait
le moins mauvais et bien il y a des
problèmes qui il faut qu'ils ont lieu et
là où il ya eu quand même à mon sens une
communication un petit peu excessive de
la part du ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est pas que lui d'ailleurs
c'est quand on a annoncé que on
trouverait les écoles et les collèges
avant tout pour les élèves de banlieue
pour les élèves ruraux etc
c'était pour eux qu'on l'ait rouvray en
fait tout le monde le savait dans la
communauté éducative
tout le monde le savait que c'était ce
qu'on allait revoir le moins pour des
raisons diverses 1 est souvent
extrêmement valable mais effectivement
cette réouverture des écoles que l'on a
fait n'a pas particulièrement profité
aux élèves les plus jeunes et plus
défavorisés et tout enseignant vous
dirai qu'un élèves décrocheurs c'est pas
la deuxième quinzaine de juin
vous leur accroché gérard paumier oui
vous êtes d'accord c'est un échec de
voir ainsi que ceux des confinement en
tout cas n'a pas du tout permis et bien
de revenir sur ces inégalités qui
avaient été laissées béantes pendant le
confinement n'ont d'autres façons on ne
peut pas être satisfait bien entendu
cela dit les gleek conditions de
décrochage existait déjà avant de
confinement je dirais que ce qui nous
arrive à tous puisque la communauté dans
son ensemble qui est touché c'est la
société doit servir à peut-être moins
penser certains fondamentaux alors il y
a bien entendu des choses
disons qu'ils qui relève de 10 ans de de
cette occurrence tragiques qu'a été le
quai locaux vides mais il y a
certainement des questions plus
structurelle à revoir et je dirais que
mais malheureusement c'est cette
catastrophe doit nous fournir
l'opportunité de roy penser en
profondeur notre manière de gérer ça de
faire penser donc cette question des
inégalités et comment réussir enfin bien
réconcilier un certain nombre d'élèves
avec l'école sylvie robert oui moi je
pense que cette période a été non
seulement un révélateur des inégalités
mais un accélérateur des inégalités
parce que forcément la question distanti
elle a montré que des enfants pour pour
des questions diverses un vraiment des
raisons diverses n'ont plus répondu à
aux enseignants et on a vu un des
enseignants qu'il n'y répondent pas
alors que maintenant alors ça a été
confiné et on voit que c'est vraiment
difficile de faire revenir ses enfants à
l'école c'est pour ça que la question de
la rentrée va être absolument
déterminante
et c'est vrai que remédiation il va
falloir vraiment travailler je pense
dans l'accompagnement encore plus
fortement de ses enfants
et puis tout simplement faire en sorte
que eh bien ça puisse si ce n'est
revenir à la normale parce que je pense
qu'il ya des questions de fond et des
questions structurelles en matière
d'éducation qui doivent se poser mais là
vraiment essayé de rattraper en tout cas
ces enfants qui ont été perdus jacques
grosperrin le mot de la fin c'est
possible de rattraper ces enfants perdus
bien sûr c'est possible éducation
nationale c'est un service public moi
j'ai confiance dans l'éducation
nationale dans ses professeurs
je crois que c'est important dans ces
chefs d'établissement parce qu'on a
tendance parfois et souvent à les
oublier
puis enfin terminée le distant ciel vous
savez lorsque les enfants sont loin
anciennement nous lorsqu'ils sont sont
loin de 2,2 du côté financier financier
partons des choses on se rend compte
qu'ils ont des difficultés parce qu'ils
n'ont pas d'ordinateur ils n'ont pas de
connexion informatique etc
donc il ya peut-être un vrai plan aussi
de l'éducation nationale à boire et
équipements parce que ce n'est pas
qu'aux mairie de faire cela je crois que
c'est aussi à l'état d'assurer c'est sûr
eh bien merci beaucoup à tous les cadres
d'avoir participé à ce débat ce débat
très apaisé
sur la question de l'école merci jacques
grosperrin merci sylvie robert merci
jean rémy girard et merci et gérard
paumier dans une demi-heure les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement au
menu de cette séance plusieurs questions
aussi sur la relance économique l'emploi
des jeunes ou encore la durée du temps
de travail le gouvernement va être
interpellé à gauche comme à droite sur
ce sujet les sénateurs noter le ont
d'ailleurs les sénateurs aient l'air ont
présenté hier leurs propres plans de
relance un plan plutôt protectionnistes
alexandre on vous retrouve salle des
conférences vous êtes avec le sénateur
et l'air de l'oise jérôme bascher sur ce
sujet justement effectivement entame les
sénateurs les républicains ont proposé
leur plan de relance avec d'abord une
mesure qui est plutôt ancien le
travailler plus pour gagner plus les
sénateurs proposent que les français
travaillent une centaine d'heures de
plus par an tout en gagnant un treizième
mois alors jérôme bascher c'est le
retour d'une vieille recette sarkozyste
le travailler plus pour gagner plus je
crois que c'est une recette qui avait
marché et donc il n'est pas interdit de
remettre des recettes qui font plaisir
elles font plaisir mais elles sont aussi
très utiles nous avons besoin d'un choc
de productivité et c'est une des façons
pour que le travail soit plus productifs
et aussi plus rémunérateurs ce qui nous
permettra d'avoir plus de consommation
et aussi d'avoir de meilleurs
compétitivité pour nos entreprises ça
peut être momentanée ça peut être plus
durable il faut pouvoir s'adapter et les
français ont été dopés jédir et les
entreprises aussi au chômage partiel
maintenant il est temps de retravailler
peut-être un peu plus pour compenser et
justement le président de la république
l'a dit les français devront travailler
davantage pour produire davantage c'est
aux salariés de faire un effort pour
relancer le pays
c'est à tout le monde la dette c'est
celle de nos enfants celle qui vient
d'être faite donc il va falloir que tout
le monde paye cette dette est donc tout
le monde doit faire un effort dans le
secteur public comme dans le secteur
privé
les entreprises comme les collectivités
c'est toute la france qui doit se mettre
au même pas du travail pour reconquérir
un peu de bien-être
alors le deuxième axe de ce plan de
relance proposé par les sénateurs
républicains
il concerne la relocalisation des
emplois en france et en europe avec une
proposition est bien la préférence
nationale et européenne notamment sur le
domaine et bien du marché de la santé
ça y est les républicains deviennent
protectionnistes
vous savez tous le dogme était fondée
sur la concurrence pure et parfaite
comme on dit en économie or on s'est
aperçu que la concurrence était ni pur
ni parfaite elle n'est pas pure avec les
chinois n'est pas parfaite non plus car
on voit bien qu'il ya eu parfois cette
fois ci au cul de l'avion et non pas au
cul du camion comme on dit des échanges
de masques pour les états unis de
masques qui de venir en france
or on voit bien toute cette concurrence
elle n'est ni pire ni parfaite il ya un
moment il faut aussi retrouver la
souveraineté ça c'est des valeurs de
droite mais ce discours de la
mondialisation la concurrence imparfaite
on l'a entendu c'est de ces dernières
années assure notamment dans la bouche
des membres du front national oui mais à
ses yeux je suis pas sûr que leur
solution d'ailleurs je ne sais pas si
elle est très localisée ou un petit peu
vers l'extérieur on ne sait pas bien
s'il songe à dire poujadiste ou s'ils
sont socialistes on ne connaît pas leur
programme économique qui n'a aucune
cohérence dans là il faut juste être
pragmatique et c'est aussi un peu pour
la commission européenne qui a été très
idéaliste
merci beaucoup jérôme bascher d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup à alexandre et on va
continuer à parler et bien de relance
économique sur ce plateau avec à mes
côtés jérôme durain bonjour jean
sénateur ps de saône et loire est
également sur ce plateau l'idée cadic
vous êtes sénateur uc représentant les
français établis hors de france d'abord
on va jeter un oeil sur les propositions
de la droite les propositions notamment
de bruno retailleau qui ont été rendus
publics hier et bien la reprise pour les
elle rime avec relocalisation sujet qui
fait plutôt consensus en ce moment
d'ailleurs quand on repense aux propos
d' emmanuel macron sur la production de
médicaments mais aussi et bien les
allaire parle de fiscalité bleu blanc
rouge de préférence européenne et
française
jérôme bascher est revenu à l'instant
là-dessus olivier cadic vous êtes
d'accord avec ça c'est un retour au
protectionnisme ce plan de relance dlr
est ce que vous le suivez j'aimerais que
puisqu'on parle par exemple du domaine
de la pharmacie on parlait de sanofi il
se trouve que qui veuille en investir
c'est formidable mais pourquoi sanofi
était parti à l'époque 96 c'est le
moment moi je suis parti il y avait la
question des impôts et taxes en bretagne
voilà moi je suis partie en grande
bretagne ed se déplacer aux états unis
mais quel était le problème c'était non
seulement un problème de fiscalité mais
aussi de bureaucratie c'est que les
états unis pouvaient fixer le propre
prix du médicament
alors qu'en france il est fixé par le
gouvernement donc si on veut attirer les
gens en france les entreprises et faire
une production locale
il faut être dans un environnement
compétitif à la fois d'un point de vue
fiscal mais aussi bureaucratique jérôme
durain est ce que vous êtes d'accord
tout d'abord avec le plan dlr vous qui
avez été très tôt pour les recoller les
relocalisations contre les excès de la
mondialisation et pour le made in france
est ce que vous pensez de ces
propositions qui émanent de la droite
sur les intentions qu'on se dise que
l'état a un rôle central à jouer dans
l'économie pour éviter les excès de la
mondialisation
je ne peux être que d'accord on peut
trouver des terrains d'entente en
attendant la sur les principes après il
faut le diable se cache dans les détails
il faut qu'on regarde comment tout ça se
déclinent et j'indique ou au passage
d'ailleurs que le club
le propre plan de relance du parti
socialiste pour un rebond économique
écologique et social met en place des
dispositifs avec la puissance publique
qui est en appui et qui protège la base
industrielle française ses brevets ses
compétences donc que qu'on se défendre
dans la mondialisation qu'on défende nos
ouvriers nos entreprises nos salariés
est une bonne chose il faut arrêter avec
la naïveté faut pas le faire n'importe
comment
et il faut le faire dans l'intérêt des
plus fragiles les plus démunis et de
ceux qui ont souffert de la crise est ce
que la france a laissé pour vous et bien
certains pontes de son industrie
jusqu'ici il ya eu des erreurs
stratégiques là dessus bon sinon c'est
évident ça se fait ça fait consensus je
pense que vous me posez la question
juste pour lever la balle et que je
puisse ce marché mais c'est évident tout
le monde le dit tout le monde le dit
c'est connu ça a été un peu tardif savez
que je suis assez proche d'arnaud
montebourg qui l'a dit très tôt sur ces
questions de 2
de souveraineté industrielle donc
maintenant il faut réagir c'est déjà un
peu tard
et est-ce que c'est emmanuel macron qui
a par exemple lâché des boucantiers
d'alstom qui est le mieux placé pour
porter cette politique on n'en est pas
sûr que tout le monde revienne à la
raison c'est une bonne chose on y arrive
est-ce qu'ils emmanuel macron et bien du
coup n'a pas fait ce qu'il dit qu'il
faut faire qu'est ce que vous pensez
pour en revenir un petit peu à la
question de sanofi il faut maintenant
quand même bien obligé un certain nombre
d'industries à rester en france pour des
raisons sanitaires et pas juste en les
attirant parce qu'on a absolument besoin
d'elle mais encore une fois vous pouvez
essayer d'attirer toutes les entreprises
que vous voulez mais les entreprises
sont dans un mauvais 1 un univers
compétitif
donc on a l'air de moi j'ai l'impression
parfois qu'on est tout seul au monde et
que le monde fonctionne autour de nous
mais quand en 2008 nous avons eu la
crise la première grande crise et
nicolas sarkozy donc était aux affaires
l'endettement de la france c'était 60 %
son pib c'était la même chose que
l'allemagne
vingt ans après dans qu'est ce que je
dis douze ans après c'est 40% de plus
que l'allemagne
pourtant l'allemagne et dans l'union
européenne l'allemagne à sa production
et donc sur son sol donc le problème il
est chez nous il a été lancé et egypte
notre erreur c'est de croire toujours
que c'est l'état qui va régler les
choses ces histoires de pôles de
compétitivité on va tout organe à celui
sur lequel nous opposer pour le coup sur
place deux états mais encore une fois on
revient toujours aux vieilles bonnes
pratiques qui sont éculés qui s'avèrent
être des mauvais qui lui donnait des
mauvais résultats
le problème c'est pas du tout de faire
ce que est en train de proposer là
aujourd'hui les républicains
le problème c'est de se mettre en
position d'être en compétition avec les
plus proches qui sont par exemple
d'accord avec vos alliés habituels de l
air et si au sénat mais je pense que il
ya un tournant qui est en train de se
faire d'un point de vue économique
chez les républicains qui est assez
préoccupant mais qui ne correspond qu'à
une partie des républicains
les républicains en deux tendances
qu'il est au niveau économique et là il
ya une tendance qui est plus en retrait
en repli mais cette tendance
elle est amenée à échouer alors il ya un
autre sujet sur lequel vous allez
peut-être vous opposer c'est dans ce
sujet clivant qui émergent à la faveur
de cette crise et le débat sur le temps
de travail
emmanuel pahud maquereau en a parlé
brièvement dimanche pour l' écoute nous
ne financerons pas ses dépenses en
augmentant les impôts notre pays est
déjà l'un de ceux où la fiscalité est la
plus lourde
même si depuis trois ans nous avons
commencé à l'abaisser la seule réponse
est de bâtir un modèle économique
durable plus fort de travail et de
produire davantage pour ne pas dépendre
des autres une seule solution travailler
et produire davantage
jérôme durain qu'est ce que vous
entendez vous dans ses propos du
président de la république je sais pas
trop
thaïlande belle je ne sais pas ça veut
dire quoi travailler plus ça veut dire
donner plus de travail à ceux qui ont
déjà du mal à travailler
est-ce que vous pensez que les
restaurateurs qui attendent les clients
qui tarde à revenir veulent travailler
plus on les fait travailler plus ceux là
est-ce que vous pensez que tous ceux qui
ont travaillé pendant la crise du coc
vide qui étaient actifs en télétravail
ou des entreprises ont besoin de
travailler plus
quelle est la place de l'offre et de la
demande dans cette affaire il ya des six
a pas de monde on travaille pourquoi
donc si c'est travailler et partager le
travail entre ceux qui ont déjà du
boulot
à quoi ça sert et qu'est ce que ça donne
à ceux qui ne travaillent pas il ya eu
un flou 1 dans les propos d'emmanuel
macro mais gérald darmanin a fait un
petit peu l'explication de texte le
lendemain il a dit que lui il était
plutôt favorable à une certaine
flexibilité au niveau local dans
certaines entreprises lorsqu'elles en
ont besoin il veut pas forcément à un
retour du débat global sur le temps de
travail et si c'est travailler plus pour
travailler tous et permettre à ceux qui
sont éloignés du marché du travail de
rentrer dans le jeu très bien mais je
suis pas certain que les accords de
performance collective voulue par michel
muriel pénicaud pardon permet de ça et
c'est plutôt une forme de dumping
moi je pense que si c'est baisser le
pouvoir d'achat de ceux qui ont pas
grand-chose qui consomment trop peu pour
affaiblir la demande et empêcher
l'économie de repartir c'est une très
mauvaise idée mais
que c'est pas ça un jour on sera bien qu
a dit qu'il faut rouvrir le débat sur le
temps de travail pour vous le faire pour
moi aujourd'hui le vraiment la
problématique c'est de se mettre dans
une position où tout est flexible
parce que en face de nous on a une
concurrence qui est diverses variées
aujourd'hui on prend conscience que la
flexibilité pour vous bien il faut la
négocier dans le cadre européen
voilà donc ces salles et qui doit être
notre notre point de comment dire où on
doit s'étalonner faut avoir une vision
européenne dans ce domaine pour pour
pouvoir jusqu'à quelle limite pour vous
mais aujourd'hui enfin la limite ça veut
dire quoi la limite la litote de temps
de travail par semaine il était fils lé
17 mai elle est définie dans le cadre de
l'union européenne donc voilà donc le
sait en terme de temps maximum s'est
défini au niveau européen
donc il faut se il faut connaître donc
les règles du jeu au niveau européenne
et puis ensuite en fonction de ça
s'adapte et on a aujourd'hui je veux
dire par exemple smic vous voyez bien
que un smig à paris et un smig en
province c'est pas la même c'est pas la
même chose en terme de de pouvoir
d'achat
donc tout ça doit se réfléchir on ne
peut pas mettre tout le monde sous la
même toise et penser que comme ça on va
s'en sortir on va compétitif on ne peut
pas mettre tout le monde sous la même
toise mais en tout cas elle est l air
propose une toise à 37 heures par
semaine dans leurs plans de relance
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je pense
que dans le débat politique d'autres
offres sont plutôt sur la baisse du
temps de travail donc il faut se poser
la question autrement je pense que on
est sortis de cette crise pour un
certain nombre d'entre nous avec une
vision un peu différente de ce devait
être l'économie le fonctionnement de la
société et des entreprises les français
veulent du pouvoir d'achat ils veulent
ils ont très claire conscience des
périls écologiques et là où j'ai un
point de différence avec olivier cadic
mais c'est connu et on assume dans une
dialectique amical c'est que moi je ne
crois pas qu'il faille s'aligner sur le
moins-disant partout néolibéralisme il a
bousillé la planète il a mis des gens
dans des situations économiques et
sociales terribles
donc il faut peut-être arrêter soit on
comprend à la faveur de la crise du
comité soit on continue comme avant
les mauvaises recettes on dérégule
partout et on abîme
les individus un dernier sujet auquel on
va s'intéresser pour ce débat très large
sur la relance c'est la question de la
fiscalité et sur ce sujet là pour le
coup est bien c'est très clair on a
entendu emmanuel macron à l'instant en
tout cas le gouvernement refuse
d'augmenter les impôts il veut même les
baisser écouter gérald darmanin
c'est un choix politique que de choisir
le terrain politique vous avancer le
travail ont choisi de choses ont choisi
la baisse des impôts
oui des impôts sur les sociétés baisse
de la taxe d'habitation
nous avons tout un tas de réformes que
nous verrons fin septembre lors du
budget présentée si j'ose dire que miser
économie et finances - l'euro continue
de continuité de baisse des impôts
on aura l'occasion de continuer à
baisser les impôts tout à fait
exactement il rend les particuliers
comme pour les entreprises ou les
particuliers en discutera et puis vous
avez les impôts pour les particuliers
n'ont envoyé baissé à la fin du monde
c'est bien sûr qu'on a des pistes nous
préparons à l'uruguay les impôts nous
continuons à baisser les impôts en tout
cas il n'y a aucune augmentation
d'impôts et y en aura aucune dans le cas
où il n'a rien annoncé de nouvelles
baisses d'impôts fin septembre mais nous
continuons par en-bas deuxième tranche
de taxe d'habitation par exemple ou est
sûre on savait ça monsieur bruno le
maire a évoqué la deuxième tranche de
baisse de liesse apposerait société par
ailleurs une réforme sur la politique
sur les brevets c'est très important
pour les entreprises
on aura l'occasion enfin cet homme d'y
revenir on va continuer à baisser les
impôts pour les ménages et pour les
entreprises jérôme durain qu'est ce que
vous pensez bien de cette politique de
la part du gouvernement
ces îles sont formidables ces gens on
sort d'une période c'était hier encore
dans les rues ou les soignants 10 la
crise du coc vide
elle est liée à la situation de
l'hôpital public des sous investissement
chronique des politiques autoritaires
qui explique la crise du coc vide le
confinement n'aurait jamais été si long
si dur abc douloureux si on a vu les
moyens l'hôpital d'accueillir les gens
malades
mais si ça passe forcément par l'impôt
là mais il faut bien trouver les
ressources de comment on fait donc
peut-être qui a effectivement des marges
de manoeuvre financières et fiscales
dans ce pays fait il ya des gens et des
sociétés dans la crise qui ont bénéficié
à plein régime
des opportunités qu'il offre à la crise
amazon par exemple ils ont fait un peu
d'argent est ce qu'on peut aller
chercher de l'argent dans la poche de
du capital plutôt que d'aller taper
encore chez les pauvres gens par des
baisses de salaires et puis la baisse de
la fiscalité les policiers qui se
plaignent aussi des moyens
comment les financent donc le service
public l'état
la régulation ça suppose qui a des
moyens publics effectivement ce se
montra de la baisse des impôts
encore et toujours ne me paraît pas
juste on peut faire des baisses d'impôts
l'allemagne vient de baisser la tva par
exemple une solution après ça me paraît
quand même particulièrement flou donc
attendons de voir ce qui propose
vraiment on va attendre de voir
septembre mais qu'est ce que vous pensez
ce que vous dit à jérôme durain n'ont
finalement on peut qu'on peut surtout
augmenter les impôts pour les plus aisés
les scènes de liesse place et la
question de la meilleure redistribution
de l'impôt pour les plus aisés on l'a
beaucoup vu sur cette dernière phase du
coc vide entre les propos de
l'économiste esther duflo l'heureux la
gauche qui réclament les retours de
liesse f
l'idée de la taxe jean valjean la taxe
heidsieck exceptionnelle pour les plus
aisés dans cette période qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
d'abord je voudrais dire que je suis
totalement d'accord avec la vision qui
est présenté par gérald darmanin et le
président de la république c'est
effectivement la france est le pays qui
est pratiquement aujourd'hui le plus
taxé on est plus taxé est donc
évidemment il faut baisser les impôts
c'est indispensable en termes de solides
de vialis que vient dire jérôme réagir à
ce que dit jérôme durain c'est que au
niveau de l'hôpital de la santé plus
d'un tiers des personnels hospitaliers
dans le domaine de la santé n'ont aucune
fonction
donc qui entrait à la santé c'est
uniquement pour des racistes ratisser
voilà donc donc c'est pas et on dépense
plus d'argent que nos voisins dans le
domaine donc si c'était dépenser plus
d'argent qu'ils amélioraient le service
on ne saurait on serait toujours en tête
des hit parades
quand on comparer nos résultats pour
revenir sur le lit sf c'est toujours
pareil on revient toujours à cette idée
il ya un bouc émissaire il suffirait
qu'ils payent et ça serait magique mais
non en réalité c'est que en france
le capital est taxé trois fois plus chez
nous que chez les autres
ça c'est un vrai problème il faut créer
de la richesse avant de vouloir la
distribuer et encore une fois les impôts
de production puisque je reviens là
dessus il faut baisser les impôts
pour les entreprises il l'a dit si on
veut attirer les appareils productifs
chez nous il faut diminuer les impôts de
production ça c'est la priorité
cela alors que l'on voit edouard
philippe le premier ministre qui arrive
salle des conférences dans cette salle
qui est jouxte l'hémicycle car nos
sommes a maintenant un 10 minutes des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement et
me connais je vous remercie tous les
deux sont re ce débat il va d'ailleurs
être largement la question de relance
économique lors de cette séance de
questions d'actualité et dont va
d'ailleurs continuer à s'intéresser à
cette question du temps de travail
puisque cette question va être au coeur
de l'intervention de la sénatrice
communiste michelle gréau mallette à
votre micro alex tanguay vous êtes celle
des conférences effectivement tam quelle
est la bonne solution pour relancer le
pays dans cette crise économique je suis
avec la sénatrice communiste michelle
gréaume bonjour madame grès home
alors est-ce que la solution de
travailler plus pour gagner plus
pourrait marcher pour relancer le pays
aujourd'hui à mao campagne travailler
plus pour gagner plus on a déjà connu ça
en 2007 avec monsieur nicolas sarkozy ça
a été un véritable échec il faut quand
même se le dire la précarité a augmenté
vaut mieux donner du travail aujourd'hui
à celui qui en a pas que de donner à
celui qu'on a déjà
je pense que c'est la meilleure solution
notamment sarkozy a voulu également
revenir sur les 35 heures en disant
comme il ya mois de travail
maintenant on travaille on va baisser
les salaires aujourd'hui c'est encore
pareil avec les accords d'entreprise
masse et sap aubin ses salaires ou ces
licenciements
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut voir les
choses aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
baisser le taux de travail c'est-à-dire
descendent à 32 eur en descendant à 32
heures on pourra permettre aux autres de
de travailler tous les jeunes de
travailler parce qu'il faut pas avoir un
double langage on peut pas dire bah
voilà on va donner plus de travail à
certains et de l'autre côté on va
reculer l'âge de la retraite
et puis on va dire on va laisser la
place aux jeunes dites moi où aller la
place aux jeunes quand c'est comme ça
profitant de la crise la cre et ça nous
a permis de voir que la france pouvait
créer des richesses ya des salariés des
entreprises qui nous ont fait voir photo
un torchon essayons de créer pas
n'importe comment pas n'importe où et
regardons ce qu'on peut faire pour
atteindre cet objectif est justement
michel rome vous parliez des jeunes
le 1er septembre sept cent mille jeunes
devraient entrer sur le marché du
travail beaucoup pourraient se retrouver
au chômage à cause de la crise
économique
eh bien quelle est la solution pour
soutenir l'emploi des jeunes est ce
qu'il faut des primes des baisses de
charges à les primes on en a parlé
maintenant il faut regarder un peu plus
dans le détail mais aujourd'hui les
jeunes qu'est ce qu'il leur faut
c'est un véritable emploi à travail bien
rémunéré ça devrait être une priorité
nationale
les formes et qu'ils aient un emploi
mais on peut pas tout choisir tout
simplement
et donc il faut faire un effort
supplémentaire notamment sur la
formation cet effort il n'a pas déjà été
fait s'il n'essaie pas suffi non ça soit
bien bien sûr on a eu des aides de
l'état regarde et on a eu le cce
mais il n'y a pas eu de contrôle
derrière quel résultat on a eu ça a été
un véritable échec d'ailleurs ça a été
même versées à des entreprises qui en
avait pas besoin
les exonérations sociales qui sont faits
pour les entreprises je vais vous dire
mon avis on fait baisser le coût du
travail une entreprise si elle donne à
bas salaires à la des exonérations ce
n'est pas logique en plus non seulement
on règle le budget de l'état mais au gré
de la sécurité sociale non plus qu'on
donnera de l'emploi plus que les caisses
vont se remplir
donc tout le monde est gagnant et plus
on va dépenser en france donc c'est le
chat qui se mord la queue
mais c'est le chat qui se mord la queue
merci beaucoup michel guillaume et je
rappelle que vous avez interrogé le
gouvernement sur cette question de
l'emploi des jeunes beaucoup alexandre
est un autre sujet qui va marquer cette
séance de questions d'actualité
et bien la question des violences
notamment à dijon où de vives tensions
ont opposé des membres de la communauté
tchétchène et des habitants d'un
quartier populaire de la ville et
alexandre vous allez être rejoints vous
êtes avec anne catherine loisier
sénatrice us et de la côte-d'or pour
parler de ce sujet effectivement en tant
que je suis avec une élue du département
de la côte d'or qui est directement est
directement concernée par cette vague de
violences qui a frappé la ville de dijon
ces dernières nuits
anne catherine loisier qu'elle est
d'abord votre réaction à cette vague
d'ultra violence qui a touché le
quartier des grésillés
ben je pense comme la plupart des
habitants
de cette belle ville et notamment du
quartier des grésillés une forme de
sidération de voir un tel déferlement de
violences pendant plusieurs jours dans
une dans une capitale provinciale comme
les dijon est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu une
faille des forces de l'ordre notamment
dans le retard pour intervenir alors je
pense pas qu'une faille des forces de
l'ordre parce que je pense qu'ils ont
fait preuve de beaucoup de sang-froid
dans les circonstances qu'ils ont eu à
gérer effectivement en effectif plutôt
réduit et je pense qu'ils ont plutôt
bien mené leur mission puisque au final
il n'y a pas à déplorer de décès enfin
eu un accident mais qu'il y ait un
accident de voiture basse avec voilà
donc je pense qu'ils ont bien bien
rempli leur mission
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est comment on n'anticipe pas un
déferlement de 200 individus armés de
provenances quand même un petit peu
suspectes sur une petite ville
provinciale comme dijon est pourquoi il
faut plusieurs jours avant de voir
arriver des enfants est d'ailleurs
effectivement sur ce sujet de
l'anticipation
le maire de dijon françois rebsamen
estime qu'il ya eu un échec du
renseignement territoriales pour
prévenir en amont les préfets d'un
risque de l'arrivée de la communauté de
chaque chaîne dans un règlement de
comptes à dijon vous êtes d'accord avec
cette analyse
je pense qu'il faut se poser les bonnes
questions après il faut encore je crois
que ce qui est arrivé à dijon est assez
exceptionnel dans son ampleur dans sa
rapidité dans sa soudaineté
et qu'il faut réfléchir aujourd'hui et
se dire comment ne pas reproduire ce
genre de scénario et comment s'organiser
pour qu'effectivement il ya une
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre en
nombre conséquent pour ne pas finalement
uniquement contrôlé que tout se passe
bien mais peut-être attendre de la part
des forces de l'ordre le véritable
rétablissement de l'or c'est à dire des
interventions mais là on est on est
génération des questions qui sont plus
lourde plus complexe et je pense qu'il
faut vraiment qu'avec les services du
ministre nous nous discutions et nous
approfondissions cette situation vous
évoquez la sidération des habitants du
quartier des grésillés beaucoup estiment
estiment qu'ils ont été abandonnés dans
cette affaire par les forces de l'ordre
vous comprenez ce sentiment et oui parce
qu'ils sont restés plusieurs jours
je dirais à observer ce qui se passait
dans les espaces publics entre une
espèce de milice ainsi qu'on l'a
qualifié d' acteurs locaux qui se sont
organisés pour c'est de se défendre
entre guillemets face aux attaques donc
des tchétchènes et autres individus
venus de l'extérieur donc serait que
c'était assez surréaliste de voir que
voilà il sait la rue était devenu un
état de non droit où finalement les
forces de l'ordre n'arrivait pas à
rétablir l'ordre
donc je comprend effectivement que ces
populations se soient sentis délaissés
livrée à elle-même en tout cas une
question sur le quartier des grésillés
et bien dans les témoignages il y à des
habitants qui ont vu des individus les
individus lourdement armés
ce quartier il a il a obtenu des fonds
notamment de la politique de la ville
est ce que cette affaire ne montre pas
l'échec des politiques de la ville
précédentes ces dernières années je
pense qu'il faut là aussi à les regarder
plus loin c'est à dire que les
difficultés étaient réelles
il ya une dizaine d'années elles ont
mobilisé des moyens publics
mais ses difficultés existent toujours
aujourd'hui c'est pas pour autant
qu'elles ont été éradiqués pas ce
conseil à des difficultés d'intégration
des difficultés d'accès à l'emploi
et ça dans les les courlis circonstances
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui c'est toujours
bel et bien réel et c'est un travail en
fait sans relâche d'accompagnement de
ces territoires je pense que nous aurons
beaucoup à faire dans les mois à venir
notamment face à l'été qui vient pour
accompagner ces quartiers difficiles
quartiers sensibles ces banlieues qui
risque de voir beaucoup des aspirations
et de sentiment d'abandon de la part de
leurs habitants et justement depuis
trois années que manuel macro est au
pouvoir et ce qu'il a vraiment bien pris
conscience de ce problème des banlieues
du problème du communautarisme également
visiblement pas suffisamment puisque là
on sent vraiment que les situations de
tensions grandissent ce qui se passe à
dijon on le retrouve malheureusement
dans peut-être dans de moindres mesures
mais j'irai presque au quotidien dans un
certain nombre de villes parisienne ou
même sur nice où il ya eu des événements
de ce genre donc on voit que c'est un
véritable sujet de société c'est à dire
la cohésion l'intégration et le pacte
républicain qui doit nous unir et quand
le président la république évoque les
mots de séparatisme est ce que cela
suffit ce ne sont que des mots au final
pour dénoncer le communautarisme le
séparatisme oui alors je pense qu'il
faut pas exacerber les tensions alors
certainement qu'il faut qualifier les
faits il faut être et se mettre d'accord
sur le diagnostic mais attention dans
ces situations vraiment de deux de
tension à ne pas exacerber les
sentiments des uns et des autres je
crois que notre président doit avoir le
souci aujourd'hui 2
d'apaiser de rassembler dans la fermeté
et en fixant le cadre de notre de notre
république
et justement sur ces tensions ces
dernières semaines elles ont vraiment
été exacerbées depuis le début du
déconfinement avec beaucoup de
manifestations plutôt violentes
comment vous jugez la société
actuellement ces dernières semaines
après notre crise sanitaire
je pense que nos politiques nous avons
le devoir de réagir et le devoir de
proposer des solutions en tout cas des
moyens d'action pour que nos citoyens
soient conscients que voilà que nous
réagissons que le problème est identifié
et que des solutions seront apportées je
pense qu'il faut absolument être réactif
et à l'écouté de ce qui se passe sur un
cadre qu'est ce que vous allez dire au
gouvernement là dans quelques instants
lors de votre question d'actualité sur
les événements de dijon et bien lui
demander comment ils envisagent à
l'avenir de tirer les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé ce qu'on a dit en matière de
peut-être peut-être un peu plus de
traçage certain nombre d'individus qui
peuvent se révéler dangereux en matière
de délais d'intervention voilà comment
est ce que demain nous allons faire en
sorte que les populations de ces
territoires se sentent davantage en
sécurité
très bien merci beaucoup anne catherine
loisier d'avoir répondu à mes questions
je vous laisse regagné l'hémicycle du
sénat pour poser votre question
d'actualité au gouvernement alors que la
séance va commencer dans quelques
instants le président du sénat gérard
larcher est arrivée au plateau pour
lancer cette séance alors pour vous
présenter un peu le programme de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
eh bien on va parler des violences est à
dijon des forces de l'ordre et de
l'emploi des jeunes les questions
d'actualité c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il y en a en séance je n'en
vois point le procès verbal est donc
adoptée sur les réserves d'usagé les
conclusions adoptées par la conférence
des présidents réunis en ce début
d'après midi sont consultables sur le
site du sénat
en l'absence d'observation d'ici la fin
de cette séance de questions au
gouvernement ou les considérons comme
adopté monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance se déroule dans les
conditions de respect des règles
sanitaires mises en place depuis le mois
de mars
je rappelle qu'à chaque fois des toyer
âgées désinfection chacun veillera au
respect des distances de sécurité et je
remercie les collègues qui sont dans
l'hémicycle mais dans une partie
légèrement supérieure de l'hémicycle qui
sont nombreux ce qui traduit
l'engagement des sénateurs la semaine
prochaine ne pourront être plus nombreux
conformément aux orientations présentées
par monsieur le questeur délégué en
conférence des présidents qui nous
permettront d'être 189 sous respect bien
sûr de la discipline les sorties ont
lieu pour les sénateurs par le fonds de
l'hémicycle et pour le gouvernement sur
le devant de même nous verrons nous
l'avons vu que ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement
les questions redeviendront pleinement
d'actualité
sous réserve bien entendu que nous
soyons attentifs à la protection
sanitaire du gouvernement monsieur le
premier ministre
ce sera aussi le cas nous n'oublions pas
les principes qui sont les nôtres
le respect des uns et des autres celui
du temps de parole qui fait partie
des équilibres je rappelle que seul le
premier ministre à une forme de liberté
absolue dans le temps de parole et que
pour les autres délai de deux minutes
n'est pas qu'un voeu pieux mais une
exigence
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue corinne féret pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président je souhaite
associer à cette question ma collègue
gisèle jourda sénatrice de l'aude
monsieur le ministre le décret du 14 mai
2001 prévoit l'attribution d'une prime
aux professionnels des établissements
publics de santé qui ont mobilisé toutes
leurs forces pour vaincre l'épidémie du
coronavirus ce décret a suscité de vives
réactions de la part des personnels
soignants
tant qu'il est injuste et inéquitable
dans son application
le montant de cette prime variant de 500
à 1500 euros
selon l'établissement où la situation
géographique partout cette distinction
est très mal vécue par les personnels
concernés qui voit un manque de
reconnaissance de la nation pour leurs
actions pour leur engagement pourtant
sans faille
sans compter que certaines professions
sont exclues de ce dispositif de primes
c'est le cas par exemple des aides à
domicile qui ont malgré la quasi absence
d'équipements de protection individuelle
au départ continuer à assumer pleinement
leur rôle en première ligne auprès des
personnes âgées dépendantes en situation
de handicap elles ont notamment aidé nos
concitoyens le plus vulnérable à
supporter visuellement pendant le
confinement
ce sont 300 mille professionnels de
l'aide à domicile qui sont exclus de la
prime qu'ovide tous les métiers exposés
au virus doivent être récompensés par la
nation le gouvernement a pris la
décision de ne verser des primes aux
personnels d'état de santé et du médico
social laissant notamment collectivités
locales le soin d'assumer les dépenses
pour certains autres professionnels dans
le contexte que nous traversons ce n'est
pas acceptable aussi ma question est
simple
que comptez vous faire pour tenir vos
promesses et garantir une équité de
traitement pour tous les professionnels
du secteur sanitaire social et
médico-social pour vous répondre la
parole et crédible secrétaire d'état
vos produits des solidarités de la santé
valable du boss j'avais la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice corinne féret sans attendre
les changements profonds qui feront
suite aux ségur de la santé cette
concertation historique qui aboutira
nous l'espérons tous aux accords de la
santé nous avons décidé en effet de
verser une prime exceptionnelle aux
professionnels qui ont permis au système
de santé de prendre soin de prendre en
charge un afflux majeur de patients
contaminés par le virus qu'ovide 19 les
différentes primes versées sont bien un
dispositif exceptionnel pour reconnaître
un engagement exception exceptionnels là
encore dans une période exceptionnelle
en parallèle de ces primes le
gouvernement s'est engagé à une
revalorisation des carrières et des
compétences ainsi que des parcours
professionnels à l'hôpital mais aussi au
sein des ehpad c'est bien dans le cadre
de la séduire deux centres de la santé
que les négociations sur les salaires et
qui répondront aux besoins légitimes des
soignants et des professionnels
paramédicaux
cette reconnaissance que la nation leur
doit tous les soignants mobilisé bon
pendant la crise sanitaire bénéficient
d'une prime défiscalisées et exonérées
de cotisations sociales
quel que soit le statut public ou privé
ou leurs activités dans les quarante
départements les plus touchés par
l'épidémie
cette prime est majorée et s'élève à
1500 euros
au sein de ces départements se sont
moins de un peu plus de 1 million un
demi million pardon d'hospitaliers qui
percevront cette prime dans les autres
départements la prime s'élèvera à 500
euros au sein de chaque service
hospitalier les plus mobilisés dans la
prise en charge des patients qu'aux vide
le directeur de l'établissement peut
d'ores et déjà relevé le montant de la
prime à son maximum pour les services ou
les agents les plus impliqués dans la
prise en charge de patients contaminés
concernant l'implication et on va vous
avez sollicité également sur les aides à
domicile
l'implication des personnels des
services à domicile n'a jamais été mise
en doute
le principe est simple l'assurance
maladie prend en charge le versement
pour tous les pistes à bisman et
services tarifier par l'assurance
maladie y compris lorsque celle ci n'est
pas un terrifie catr unique
ce mécanisme conduit des services de
soins infirmiers à domicile et a
bénéficié de la prime puisqu'ils sont
concernés par le versement de
l'assurance maladie les services d'adado
medad
et d'accompagnement à domicile quant à
eux ne sont pas tarifé l'assurance
maladie donc c'est bien au département
que relève cette compétence il s'agit
bien des départements contrats vont être
très bon exemple notamment être là
marteau de moselle qui s'engagent
fortement pour leurs propres salariés je
vous remercie alain perret pour quelques
secondes
oui merci j'entends votre réponse madame
la secrétaire d'état
mais visiblement vous vous n'entendez
pas la colère la colère qui s'est
exprimée hier encore pour demander et
réclamé plus de reconnaissance plus de
justice et moins d'inégalités et je
voudrais avant de céder la parole
notre collègue alain fouché s'est levé
notre nouvelle collègue madame marie
noëlle solaire sénatrice du doubs qui
remplace martial burqa je lui souhaite
la bienvenue dans notre assemblée dans
cet hémicycle et au céda la parole est
maintenant notre collègue alain fouché
pour le groupe les indépendants vous
avez la parole
peut-être le ministre malgré le
terrorisme
les casseurs et la délinquance les
policiers et les gendarmes assurent jour
et nuit le maintien de l'ordre souvent
au péril de leur vie
c'est dire à quel point est malvenu la
campagne contre les violences policières
menées par des identitaires racialiste
dont l'idéologie et les objectifs sont à
l'opposé de l'anti racisme qu ils font
mine de professer cette campagne vise à
imposer une grille de lecture américaine
à la situation française qui n'a
pourtant rien à voir une grande majorité
de nos concitoyens en sont choqués
airplus des antagonismes suscitée par ce
que le président de la république
appelait des séparatistes la vérité est
que l'immense majorité des violences le
constate les français sont celles qui
portent atteinte à l'ordre républicain
des guet-apens tendu autour de sécurité
et trafic de drogue
l'incroyable guerre des gangs qui vient
d'avoir lieu à 10 ans dans ces
conditions des discours scandaleux de
certains agitateurs
bien connu plein d'arrière pensées qui
portent atteinte à la réputation des
policiers et des gendarmes sont plus
qu'un convenant la police française
n'est pas raciste et ses membres
acceptent pleinement que les doutes de
certains soient sanctionnés car c'est la
condition de leur exemplarité
mais les forces de l'ordre doivent
savoir qu'elles bénéficient de l'entier
soutien des institutions de la
république de leurs autorités de tutelle
et de la très grande majorité du peuple
français
monsieur le ministre les syndicats de
policiers demandent que vous ré a remis
à la police
juridiquement moralement et
matériellement
comment pouvez vous comptez vous faire
pour vous répondre la parole et aux
milices de matériaux recyclés stellaire
de la parole monsieur le dessinateur
foucher vous l'avez dit chaque jour
chaque nuit à chaque instant la police
gendarmerie interviennent sur nos
territoires dans l'urbain dans la
ruralité dans des moments de tension
dans le quotidien pour protéger pour
protéger les français est trop souvent
vous l'avez dit ils font face à des
provocations à des insinuations à des
menaces à des injures et à des mises en
cause incessantes et je vous remercie de
la qualité de votre témoignage
d'expérience d'un homme de terrain qui
montre combien nous savons que à chaque
fois qu'elle est sollicitée la police la
gendarmerie répondent présents et sont
engagés totalement et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je suis fier fier de
défendre sans cesse depuis 20 mois que
je suis ce premier défenseur de nos
forces de sécurité intérieure les femmes
et les hommes qui incarnent cela
pourquoi parceque ils sont les gardiens
de la paix ils sont les gardiens de ce
que nous avons de plus précieux
le pacte républicain et vous avez raison
monsieur sénateurs il ya aujourd'hui des
jeux politiques menées par certains
agitateurs qui vise à casser le pacte
républicain et pour agresser notre pacte
républicain que font-ils
ils s'en prennent au gardien du pacte
républicain à nos policiers à nos
gendarmes et nous avons bien née
évidemment il a besoin le besoin la
nécessité l'obligation de les défendre
de façon systématique
nous le faisons en l'airé armand comme
vous le dites avec un budget qui a
augmenté de 1 milliard d'euros pour les
forces de sécurité depuis le début de ce
quinquennat
nous devons le faire aussi techniquement
matériellement nous devons le faire
juridiquement et je voudrais rebondir
sur deux propositions qui me paraissent
majeur aujourd'hui la première c'est
celle d'équipé de façon beaucoup plus
massive nos forces de sécurité
intérieure de caméras piétons de caméras
piétons efficace qui dure avec des
batteries suffisante pour faire en sorte
qu'il soit protégé dans le jeu des
images qu'on leur oppose souvent
et puis ils doivent être défendus
juridiquement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai demandé qu'un groupe de
travail autour du directeur général de
la gendarmerie nationale et de la police
nationale sont mis en oeuvre pour que
systématiquement quand ils sont victimes
doute rage de violence de menaces il est
une procédure simplifiée et que nous
puissions leur assurer la garantie de la
défense juridique à laquelle ils ont
droit
je vous remercie merci la parole et à
notre collègue roger karoutchi pour le
groupe l'est républicain
le projet vise la société française va
mal
la société française va mal
naturellement parce qu'à la pandémie
naturellement parce qu' à la crise
économique mais elle va mal aussi parce
qu'elle est profondément fracturé parce
qu'elles se demandent si encore
aujourd'hui le pacte républicain l'ordre
républicain et le destin collectif de la
nation france ont encore un sens est-ce
que face aux coups de boutoir certes de
la délinquance de plus en plus violente
mais aussi de toute cette contestation
de ce qu'est la france de ce qu'est
l'autorité de l'état partout ces groupes
black blocks racialiste indigéniste
ultra communautariste
est ce qu'il y a encore un destin commun
pour ce pays monsieur le premier
ministre
est ce que en quelques mots devant la
représentation nationale
vous nous dire ce qu'est votre
conception de l'autorité de l'état et de
l'ordre républicain
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs sueur sénateur karoutchi la
société française pas mal vous l'avez
dit est à bien des égards
je crois que je suis d'accord avec vous
non pas que tout irait mal gardons nous
ça n'est pas du tout le sens de votre
question gardons nous de dire ou de
penser que tout irait mal en france ce
n'est pas le cas nous avons des atouts
extraordinaires vous les savez et notons
ne tombons pas dans ce travers français
au pessimisme et à l'auto dénigrement
mais soyons lucides comme vous l'êtes et
disons qu'à côté de ces atouts à côté de
ses chances remarquable que nous avons
en france
nous connaissons des difficultés
sérieuses des difficultés économiques
des difficultés sociales et peut-être
même aussi je ne dirais pas des
difficultés morales car le terme aurait
pu avoir un sens il ya longtemps il a
aujourd'hui un sens qui ne correspond
plus à la réalité
enfin en tout cas au sens que nous lui
donnons mais des difficultés alors
disons les politiques
qu'est ce qu'une nation se référant à ce
référendum ce plébiscite quotidien
cette volonté quotidienne de s'inscrire
dans une longue histoire qui nous
dépassent très largement dont la
complexité nous dépassent très largement
et de vivre ensemble et de construire
quelque chose ensemble une nation ce
n'est pas simplement regarder le passé
et le prendre tel qu'il est c'est
construire à partir de se passer c'est
imaginer l'endroit où nous voulons
aboutir en tant que peuple et bien de ce
point de vue là de ce point de vue là
nous avons manifestement une difficulté
à nous projeter
certains remettent en cause
explicitement les fondements du pacte
républicain
d'autres
à mon sens de façon plus insidieuse et
probablement plus dangereuse remettent
en cause ses fondements
sans le dire et lorsque on revient sur
l'idée de liberté
lorsque l'on revient sur l'idée
d'égalité en droits
lorsque l'on revient sur le principes de
l'état de droit de l'autorité de l'état
lorsque l'on revient sur le respect qui
est dû à chaque citoyen lorsqu'on leur
revient lorsque l'on revient sur l'idée
même de civisme
si notre régime s'appelle la république
c'est parce qu'elle a eu des
prédécesseurs et une des vertus
cardinales de la république à rome
c'était le civisme c'est à dire non pas
l'exemplarité de tel ou tel mais bien
l'idée que chacun chacun quelles que
soient ses responsabilités qu'il soit
élu ou non et dieu sait qu'on aimait les
élections aussi à rome dépositaire d'une
parcelle de ce qu'est le bien commun et
bien ce civisme
on le voit comme progressivement dissous
le respect de l'état pour le voit tous
les jours
remis en cause non pas parce que l'état
serait irréprochable
c'est pas parce que l'état soit
irréprochable qu'il faut le respecter
cela parce qu'il saurait mieux que les
autres
ça se saurait c'est parce qu'il est
l'émanation de notre nation et parce
qu'il est là pour faire respecter un
certain nombre de règles qui sont
essentiels à l'intérêt commun l'autorité
de l'état
c'est la capacité monsieur le sénateur à
faire respecter la loi c'est la loi qui
doit prévaloir dans un état de droit
c'est la loi qui doit prévaloir dans la
république la loi et on voit bien que la
force parfois la met en cause on voit
bien que telle ou telle bande que tel ou
tel groupe parfois que tel ou tel
individu veut la faire céder veut la
brise et veulent à remettre en cause ce
n'est pas un combat récent vous savez
bien monsieur le sénateur c'est un
combat éternel mais c'est un combat qui
aujourd'hui dans notre pays se pose avec
peut-être encore plus d'acuité qu'il ne
s'est posé dans les années qui précèdent
et c'est un fait et bien face à cela il
faut je le crois essayer non pas de
faire taire les débats politiques
ils sont indispensables et jamais il ne
faut les faire taire mais essayez
derrière les débats politiques de
dessiner cet esprit de concorde sur
l'essentiel pas surtout sur l'essentiel
sur les valeurs de la république
il faut soutenir ceux qui font le combat
de la république ministre de l'intérieur
a mille fois raison de soutenir les
forces de l'ordre elles sont au coeur de
ce combat pour la république mais elles
ne sont pas les seuls elles ne sont pas
les seuls
la républicaine et aussi avec les
professeurs la république est née aussi
avec les administrateurs ce qu'ils
construisaient ceux qui organisaient
avec ses représentants de la force
publique
nous leur devons le respect tous et
parfois parce que nous avons le droit de
les critiquer nous allons impôts de là
et nous les dénigrent ont parfois nous
leur donc nous ne leur donnons pas
toujours les moyens de mettre en oeuvre
leur mission la question vous poser très
large monsieur le sénateur et je sais
que vous et moi nous pourrions disserter
des heures sur ce sujet mais pour moi la
république
ce sont des principes simples c'est
l'état de droit c'est le respect de
l'état
c'est l'autorité de l'état et c'est au
delà de tout ça peut être encore plus le
civisme qui fait que être un citoyen ça
n'est pas simplement être un homme qui a
des droits
c'est être un homme ou une femme qui a
des droits et des devoirs
je me suis toujours à titre personnel
monsieur le sénateur étonné de ce qui à
l'époque où le service militaire était
obligatoire vous faisait des leçons
longue comme le bras sur la république
et qui parfois avait eu la faiblesse
trouvé la solution d'échapper au service
militaire
elle nous connaissons tous ceux là c'est
le contraire du civis et c'est parfois
des tentations qui sont très
individuelle est très personnel
voilà ce que je vais vous dire monsieur
le sénateur monsieur gentil monsieur le
premier ministre la république c'est la
liberté c'est l'égalité c'est la
fraternité c'est la laïcité les l'état
c'est aussi le garant de l'unité de la
nation
et lorsque la société de plus en plus
violente est de plus en plus fracturées
alors une fausse appuyer pleinement sur
ceux qui défendent la république et on
ne peut pas au nom de la liberté
accepter n'importe quel type de
contestation de critiques ou de violence
et le rôle de la police de la république
écrit le rôle de la gendarmerie à
l'intérieur du pays sont essentiels pour
soutenir cette république pour garantir
l'autorité de l'état pour être les
représentants de ce que l'avenir doit
réserver à l'ensemble des français
de la même manière que c'est le rôle de
nos forces armées à l'extérieur
la seule chose monsieur le premier
ministre que l'ensemble des français
vous demande
oui nous devons respecter les forces de
l'ordre oui nous devons respecter les
forces de sécurité en france et ailleurs
mais nous devons aussi tous nous dire
que les critiques violentes ne peuvent
pas être acceptées que la police comme
la gendarmerie sont des corps par
définition au service de la république
il peut y avoir des fautes personnelles
il doit y avoir des sanctions mais il
doit y avoir toujours toujours le
respect de ceux qui défendent la
république n'est fait
ma parole et à notre collègue anne
catherine loisier pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur et
revient donc sur les terribles
événements qui ont secoué les quartiers
de dijon et de cheminots ces derniers
jours je voudrais d'abord souligner la
présence de monsieur le secrétaire
d'état hier à dijon une présence
essentielle après quatre jours de
violences urbaines
une présence attendue par une population
sidéré face à des rixes des rixes et des
milices qui elle a subi pendant
plusieurs jours avec le sentiment
parfois d'être livrée à elle-même une
présence attendue bien sûr par les
forces de l'ordre et par les services
préfectoraux qui ont avec les moyens
disponibles avec beaucoup de sang-froid
contenu une situation sans précédent
donc vous avez annoncée des effectifs
supplémentaires en matière de maintien
de l'ordre
vous avez réaffirmé la détermination de
l'état à poursuivre les auteurs des
faits allait sanctionner cela devait
être fait mais pour autant monsieur le
ministre nous savons c'est fait
aujourd'hui ne sont malheureusement pas
isolé et plusieurs villes en france
connaissent des débordements des
représailles
organisé par des communautés rivales
parce que monsieur le secrétaire d'état
a appelé les voyous de plus en plus
lourdement armés et qui se font justice
eux mêmes ça a été dit lorsque l'état de
droit et la république sont menacés dans
leur fondement nous devons faire bloc
nous devons bien sûr soutenir nos forces
de l'ordre et nous devons aussi adapter
nos actions et nos moyens
comment donc monsieur le ministre un
rassemblement de près de 200 individus
tchétchène russe visiblement autres
venant de france est semble-t-il
d'ailleurs au delà de nos frontières
mobilisés via les réseaux sociaux armés
et organisés quasiment militairement
n'ont pas n'ont ils pas été anticipée
par les services de renseignement
pourquoi at il fallu attendre trois
jours avant que des renforts soient
effectivement affectés et enfin plus
globalement phase aller au développement
de telles violences et aux besoins de
sécurité de nos populations
comment pensez-vous faire évoluer
l'organisation et les moyens des forces
de l'ordre merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'intérieur après le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice à travers
votre témoignage vous rebondissez une
nouvelle fois sur ce sujet majeur le
fait que jamais nos forces de sécurité
routière ne rechigne quand elles sont
sollicitées et vous avez raison
au moment où ce groupe d'individus est
apparu dans la ville de dijon
il n'y avait pas eu d'anticipation en
matière de renseignement et pourtant les
forces de sécurité intérieure qui
n'était pas numériquement en capacité de
faire face qui n'étaient pas préparés
ont répondu présent et elles n'ont cessé
de répondre présent ensuite le préfet a
eu connaissance de cela j'ai changé avec
le maire de dijon
j'ai échangé avec le préfet je lui ai
demandé de piloter personnellement la
situation pour faire en sorte qu' il n'y
ait pas ces échauffourées
je dirais bande contre bond et encore je
ne sais pas si on peut qualifier comme
ça cette horde de sauvages totalement
insupportable vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice
il n'est pas question qu'il y ait un
mètre carré dans notre pays où la
république recule y compris face à ces
violences extrêmes et nous devons faire
en sorte que signé nulle part d' état de
non droit et que l'état soit toujours
présent pour juguler juguler ces dérives
totalement insupportable totalement
inacceptable et le phénomène de violence
qu'a connu dijon pendant quatre jours
même si la nuit dernière les choses
étaient apaisées et malgré cela j'ai
demandé au préfet que près de 200 hommes
femmes de la gendarmerie de la police
reste présente j'ai demandé que la berri
et que le raid reste présent aussi dans
les jours qui viennent et ils
reviendront en tant que de besoin
tout comme j'ai demandé aussi à nos
services de police de veillée sous
l'autorité du ministère de la justice à
ce que l'identification des auteurs de
ces exactions commises dès samedi se
poursuivent et qui est des recherches
individuelles pour qu'ils ne soient pas
laissés libres l'idée qu'il serait
impunis ils ne seront pas impunis
madame la sénatrice vous l'avez dit nos
forces de sécurité intérieure ont
répondu elles ont rendu avec
l'engagement elles ont répondu avec le
courage et elle mérite pour cela d'être
salué je sais l'émotion je la partage ce
qui s'est passé est inacceptable
il est insupportable et sachez que
que ce soit en france nous ferons
reculer ces pratiques de voyous a le
loisir vous avez quelques secondes mais
je salue bien évidemment comme vous de
monsieur le ministre la réaction des
services préfecture des forces de
l'ordre mais nous n'avons pas à déplorer
de plus grave considération parce que
notamment ces individus tchétchène et
autres sont partis d'eux-mêmes ou trois
jours qu'en serait-il si il était resté
c'est cela à quoi nous devons réfléchir
et comment nous devons nous adopter
mercy la parole et à l'auto collègue
julien bargeton pour le groupe de la
république en marche
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur gabriel attal
chacun a en mémoire les personnes qui
dans les établissements qui accueillent
des personnes âgées dépendantes ont
parfois souffert de la maladie parfois
sont morts sans que les familles
puissent les rejoindre et avec un
personnel qui était courageux et épuisé
je voudrais désormais dans cette
question me tourner vers la jeunesse
nous avons fait le choix de mettre
l'économie en dessous de la santé et ce
choix nous fait honneur
mais c'est un choix collectif de la
société il ne doit pas aboutir à une
rupture entre les générations
il ne doit pas aboutir à un décrochage
vis-à-vis des jeunes les jeunes actifs
sont durement impactée par le chômage
qui s'annonce 10% de baisse de la masse
salariale peut être un million deux cent
mille emplois détruits
derrière ces chiffres terribles il y à
des hommes et des femmes et notamment
des jeunes actifs acquis nous avons
rendu hommage je pense pas simplement
aux internes de médecine mais aussi bien
sûr à toutes les professions qui étaient
en première ligne
je pense aussi aux jeunes qui sont en
étude ou qui vont rentrer dans la vie
professionnelle
ça n'a jamais été simple cette étape
mais avec la crise du coronavirus
parfois l'inquiétude se transforme en
anxiété parce que les contrats précaires
ont pu ne pas être renouvelé ce pacte
des générations j'y suis
très attaché c'est un thème qui lui est
cher nous devons mettre la jeunesse au
coeur de la relance
nous lui devons un plan
d'investissements massifs dans la
formation dans l'éducation dans tout ce
qui la concerne et notamment également
bien sûr les sujets au delà des sujets
d'emplois donc monsieur le ministre ma
question quelles sont les solutions pour
faire face à la crise concernant les
jeunes et de manière générale quels sont
les contours de la relance de leur
relance pour la jeunesse de ce pays
merci beaucoup pour vous répondre la
parole et co secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'éducation monsieur merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur julien bargeton comme vous je
refuse que cette crise puisse alimenter
une fracture entre les générations et
j'ai été frappé par un certain nombre de
discours qu'on a pu entendre pendant
cette crise qui consistait à présenter
les jeunes comme un risque et les
personnes âgées comme un poids parce que
ce qu'on a vu et notamment au moment du
confinement c'est précisément l'inversé
on a vu des jeunes engagés pour venir en
aide à des personnes âgées et des
personnes vulnérables et isolées chez
elles pour les aider à leur portée leur
course leurs médicaments et on a vu des
personnes âgées qui étaient confinées
chez elles qui ont donné de leur temps à
distance pour accompagner notamment en
termes de soutien scolaire des enfants
qui en avaient besoin précisément ma
conviction c'est que cette crise
elle montre encore davantage le besoin
de lien intergénérationnel et toutes les
possibilités que nous avons pour créer
des ponts entre les générations et
incarner ce pacte générationnel que vous
développez que vous évoquez inter
générationnelle évidemment il ya des
inquiétudes
il ya des inquiétudes pour les centaines
de milliers de jeunes qui recherchent un
apprentissage
il ya des inquiétudes pour les sept cent
mille jeunes qui doivent entrer sur le
marché du travail
il ya des inquiétudes pour les centaines
de milliers d'étudiants qui ont
l'habitude tous les étés de à travailler
pour mettre des sous de côté financer
leur année universitaire ensuite et qui
ne savent pas si cet été ils pourront
travailler et c'est précisément pour
répondre à ces inquiétudes qui sont
aussi celles des parents qui sont aussi
celles des grands parents que nous
travaillons avec jean michel blanquer
avec muriel pénicaud avec bruno le maire
pour apporter des réponses
les premières réponses très fortes ont
été apportées par muriel pénicaud
s'agissant
l'apprentissage avec des mesures
massives d'autres suivront dans les
semaines à venir c'est à cela que nous
inviter le président de la république
sous l'autorité du premier ministre dans
son intervention de dimanche à avoir ce
grand plan de relance pour la jeunesse
pas uniquement pour protéger la jeunesse
des risques économiques mais bien comme
vous l'avez dit pour placer la jeunesse
au coeur de la relance parce que les
entreprises les secteurs d'activité
d'avenir sur lesquels nous allons parier
auront besoin de la créativité et de la
mobilisation des jeunes pour relever le
pays la parole est là notre collègue
nathalie delattre pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nos jeunes seront ils les
victimes collatérales de la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons ils sont
huit cent mille à s'apprêter à entrer
dans la vie active
craignant d'être une génération
sacrifiée la variable d'ajustement d'un
marché de l'emploi totalement
déstructuré les difficultés économique
impactant nombre de nos tpe et pme qui
sont les premiers employeurs par contrat
d'apprentissage ou de
professionnalisation fragilise ses voies
d'insertion professionnelle aussi
l'annoncé du gouvernement d'une aide
pour l' embauche entre six et huit mille
euros selon l'âge de l'apprenti jusqu'en
février 2021 est la bienvenue
mais cette béquille financière ne
garantit pas le maintien dans l'emploi
au contraire elle risque de créer un
effet d'aubaine trompe l'oeil
il faut donc à sortir ses ailes d'une
promesse de contrat plus sécurisant à la
clé il faut également que les
entreprises puissent bénéficier des
mêmes aides pour les plus de 26 ans aux
contrats de professionnalisation
enfin celles qui réussiront à embaucher
nos jeunes de moins de 30 ans sur un
contrat plus classiques doivent pouvoir
bénéficier de l'exonération des charges
il faut aussi déverrouiller les freins à
l'embauché sur les mesures
complémentaires de l'emploi je pense
notamment à l'examen des permis de
conduire
j'ai écrit vendredi au ministre de
l'intérieur pour l'alerter sur la
situation catastrophique qui se profile
dans plusieurs départements
en gironde le confinement à créer un
stock de plus de 6000 examen en attente
au nouveau qu'il s'agit de chaque jour
le nombre d'examinateurs absent pour
venir
lité les mesures d'hygiène et l'absence
de solution par des cessions
complémentaires conduisent des jeunes
aujourd'hui à refuser des emplois à
cause d'un système en panne qui démontre
là toutes ses failles
les jeunes ne peuvent pas passer le
permis en temps et en heure et il le
paie cash
alors madame la ministre si nous ne
pouvons pas nous serrer la main nous
devons nous serrer les coudes pour nos
enfants et co construire avec l'ensemble
des partenaires de l'emploi un plan
ambitieux pour l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes le temps
presse
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole est battable la milice du travail
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice nathalie delattre mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je pense qu'ici nous partageons tous une
conviction très forte n'est pas question
d'accepter qui est une génération
sacrifiée
ce n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
possible humainement où nos enfants nos
petits enfants
ça n'est pas possible économiquement ou
la perte de compétences que ça
représenterait ça n'est pas possible
socialement dans le la vision de
l'intergénération qui évoquait gabriel
atallah l'instant c'est pas possible
politiquement en aucun cas ça n'est
possible et pour ça il faut agir car
effectivement si nous n'agissons pas il
ya un risque compte tenu de la crise
économique et sociale qui suit la crise
sanitaire à pic il investirait plus sur
sa jeunesse n'investit plus sur son
avenir
nous ne faisons pas simplement pour les
jeunes nous faisons pour nous tous pour
tous les français je crois que c'est
important de prendre conscience que cet
investissement de la jeunesse que le
président de la république a appelé de
ses voeux
eh bien ça concerne tout le monde alors
que faire vous l'avais dit il ya une
première étape sur l'apprentissage qui a
été prises d'urgence pourquoi parce que
la concertation que j'avais mené avec
les partenaires sociaux la demande du
président de la république et du premier
ministre avait déjà porté ses fruits et
qu'il fallait aller vite car on sait
bien qu'à une certaine saisonnalité dans
la signature des contrats
d'apprentissage donc 5000 euros pour les
moins de 18 ans 8000 euros de primes
pour l'embauché d'un jeune de plus 18
ans exactement à quelques euros près le
coût d'un contrat d'apprentissage ce
qu'on dit aux entreprises c'est dans ce
contexte il faut continuer à informer
former investi ses investigations la
jeunesse créé les compétences
on comprend la situation difficile et
pour la première année nous prenons
l'intégralité quasi intégralement des
coûts à la charge de l'état
et puis vous avez parlé du permis de
conduire c'est pour ça qu'il ya une aide
au permis de conduire dans
l'apprentissage de plus la réforme dans
le passé et c'est un sujet que nous
évoquons beaucoup avec le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est un des sujets clés
effectivement de l'autonomie des jeunes
ça fait partie de des actions qui
peuvent être traitées dans un plan de
relance mais encore une fois
serrons nous les coudes vous avez raison
investir sur la jeunesse est une
priorité
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue michel rhéaume pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes avaient la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre le président de la république a
déclaré dimanche lors de son allocution
télévisée qu'il fallait je le cite bâtir
un modèle économique durable plus fort
travailler et produire davantage le
propos méritent d'être éclaircies à
l'heure où des centaines de milliers de
personnes ont perdu leur emploi
et autant vous subir le même sort dans
les semaines à venir
le travailler plus pour gagner plus
n'est pas une idée neuve pour un nouveau
monde puisque le concept fut créée par
nicolas sakozy travailler plus c'est
l'objectif après avoit appartenance
utiliser la crise sanitaire pour
multiplier dès maintenant les
dérogations au droit du travail et à la
protection des salariés vous encourager
à multiplier les accords d'entreprise
dit de performance véritable chantage à
l'emploi où l'on demande de choisir
votre licenciement et diminution de
salaire comme chez derichebourg ou
ryanair les premières victimes de votre
politique sont les salariés peu diplômés
et les jeunes déjà durement touchée par
les consulter de les conséquences du
confinement
pourquoi vous obstinez vous dans ses
choix qui n'ont pas donné de résultats
probants
sauf pour les actionnaires quand
allez-vous faire le choix d'une économie
orientée vers l'emploi au service d'une
autre production qui protège et qui
donne du travail au plus grand nombre
allez vous enfin partager le travail
pour permettre l'épanouissement de
chacun
ne pas contraindre toujours plus ceux
qui ont un emploi en précarisant les
autres cette voie nouvelle vous devez
l'explorer et ne pas rester bloqués sur
les vieux dogmes libéraux pour vous
répondre la parole est à mme la ministre
du travail madame pénicaud monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs dans la sénatrice michel
gréaume le président effectivement
appelé la collectivité nationale à
travailler davantage
quel est le sujet en france
je pense que nous serons d'accord à peu
près tous pour dire que pourra avoir un
au système de solidarité comme nous le
voulons tous en france il faut produire
la richesse nationale
c'est la richesse nationale qui produit
aussi la capacité est un grand pays être
compétitif mais aussi assurer un haut
niveau de protection de solidarité
nationale pour produire la richesse
il ya un élément clé c'est le travail et
c'est pas vous qui me contredirez
puisque il peut y avoir des débats sur
la part du travail dans la croissance
enfin toute personne ne niera que le
travail crée de la richesse nationale
or aujourd'hui en france déjà avant la
crise nous étions en train de réduire le
chômage mais on vient de loin on vient
de vivre trente ans de chômage de masse
le fait qu' il y ait autant de gens qui
ne travaillent pas qui ne peuvent pas
travailler en france oui est un été un
drame social pour eux mais aussi un
manque pour la nation et donc la
priorité aujourd'hui c'est que tous
puissent travailler
or évidemment qu'il y à un risque
aujourd'hui que le chômage repart après
le best force on rappelle que il ya
quatre mois exactement ici même nous
parlions des 8,1 pour cent de taux de
chômage qui était le plus bas taux
depuis 11 ans et des poussières pour son
apprenti nous étions dans une dynamique
avec de l'investissement fort de
l'investissement international quand
vous n'avez jamais lyon devenue le
premier pays d'europe
des signaux qui était sans être tous au
vert largement orienté ouvert évidemment
la crise économique et sociale qui ne me
remets pas en cause les fondamentaux de
la france que nous avons réparé par les
différents réforme en bonne partie mais
qui remet en cause de façon exogène la
dynamique dans lequel on était pose
cette question et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut
effectivement faire en sorte que tous
ceux qui étaient au chômage par salle
retrouve le contrat de travail puisse
être activé pour ce qui était leur cdd
et intérimaires et des chances de
retrouver un travail que la jeunesse et
des perspectives d'avenir parce que 700
milles arrivent sur le marché du travail
que tous les parents ont grâce à
l'action du ministre et du cassiot
nationale lundi prochain puisse
travailler sans être obligé de rester
chez eux pour cent la solution de garde
d'enfants toute cette mobilisation pour
que tout le monde peut travailler et
vite
il sera essentiel pour maintenir
l'activité demain l'activité c'est
l'emploi et donc c'est cette dynamique
que nous voulons encourager
très rapidement il faut pas attendre
l'emploi n'attendra pas les un chemin
nous voie empruntée c'est celui d'un
partage équitable des richesses
produites et nouvelle réduction du temps
de travail
alors que la moyenne de travail est
actuellement de 39 heures dans notre
pays seule une étape supplémentaire dans
la réduction du temps de travail y avait
32 eur permettrait le travail de toutes
et tous la france qui a une des plus
grande productivité au monde en a les
moyens
quelle société voulons-nous celle de la
précarité et du chômage de masse ou
celle qui permet à tout le monde de
travailler merci la parole est à deux
trois collègues max brisson bon le
groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
refusant de faire nation des minorités
hystériser veulent réécrire l'histoire
de france on macule la statue du général
de gaulle on appelle à déboulonner louis
xiv napoléon jules ferry au crash sur
les figures qui ont bâti notre histoire
d tentation obscurantiste guette notre
société certes dimanche le chef de
l'état condamné une ré culture haineuse
ou fausses on ne déboulonnera pas de
statut at il martelé
ces propos est-il pour autant ceux du
candidat qu'il fût déclarant que la
colonisation était un crime contre
l'humanité une vraie barbarie pour
laquelle il devait présenter ses excuses
sur le buste de jean baptiste colbert
grand commis d'état et qui fait notre
pays une puissance navale sous des
auspices de jules ferry qui préside à
notre institution et fonda notre école
républicaine
pouvez-vous nous assurer que les travaux
historiques et scientifiques qui replace
toujours l'action des femmes et des
hommes dans leur époque seront protégés
êtes vous prêt à ne jamais laisser
réécrire l'histoire à ne jamais laisser
les émotions du moment faire le tri
entre zones d'ombré et passages étant
selon pouvez-vous nous assurer que l'on
continuera à écrire et enseigner
l'histoire de france non sous la
dictature d'une pensée militante
largement communautariste mais avec
l'esprit civique kettering et la
recherche de l'universalisme qui
caractérise l héritage des lumières pour
vous répondre la parole qu'à monsieur le
problème nous
je suis président mesdames et messieurs
comme le disait sénateurs imminent qui a
siégé près de 18 ans dans cette
assemblée
la révolution est un bloc l'histoire de
france est un bloc la révolution pour
aller dans le sens du président
retailleau est un bloc et dans la
révolution nous prenons condorcet et
saint-just danton et robespierre valmy
et la vendée le général dumas et le
général bonaparte
nous prenons tout parce que parce que
parce qu'en fait en vérité monsieur le
sénateur nous n'avons pas le choix c'est
notre histoire avec des choses glorieuse
avec des choses plus compliquées et même
avec des choses qui ne sont en rien de
leurs yeux et qui sont franchement
sombre peut-on me désigner une période
de l'histoire un homme ou une femme qui
ayant fait quelque chose
serais tu de toute évidence et dans tous
les aspects lumineux et n'aurait pas sa
part d'ombré
sérieusement
je sens qu'au sénat on me dit il y à
gérard larcher
[Musique]
je crains monsieur le président que même
vous
plus sérieusement avant moi il ya eu
l'abbé grégoire ici monsieur le
président monsieur le président même lui
même les non notre histoire et et
glorieuse et est compliquée et vouloir
procéder à une forme d'épuration
mémorielle me paraît aussi dangereux
d'une certaine façon que vouloir
procéder à d'autres types d'épuration
nous devons garder notre histoire en
face évidemment et au fond ce c'est ce
que nous faisons c'est pas toujours
facile d'ailleurs
et d'ailleurs c'est peut-être le seul
point sur lequel je me distingue un tout
petit peu de votre question monsieur le
sénateur vous dites est ce que est ce
que vous allez empêcher qu'on réécrivent
l'histoire mais la vérité dans le
processus scientifique qu'est l'histoire
c'est que l'histoire se récrie en
permanence la vision que l'on a
aujourd'hui d'un certain nombre de
grands hommes ou de grande époque de
grands événements et peut-être un peu
différente c'est vrai de celle qui
prévalait il ya trente ans où il ya 200
ans bien sûr bien sûr on ne lit plus
aujourd'hui le règne de françois 1er
comme on le lisait à l'époque où
quelques années après mais justement
nous sommes au sénat le haut lieu de la
république et nous travaillons sous les
auspices de saint louis
bah oui parce que c'est l'histoire de la
france je voudrais dire monsieur le
sénateur pour aller dans votre sens que
comme vous sans doute j'ai été
profondément choqué parce que je pense
que ça traduit une profonde
je ne trouve pas le mot mais en tout cas
quelque chose qui ne va pas j'ai été
prof au quai profondément choqué qu à
fort de france
on déboulonne les statuts de victor
schoelcher à fort de france qui a été de
même et peut-être pourrions nous engager
un combat commun sur le sénateur
profondément déçu non pas choqué parce
que on a essayé de rattraper le coup
mais profondément déçu que la république
la quatrième d'abord la cinquième
ensuite ne reconstruit pas la statue au
général dumas qui a été fondue par les
nazis en 1940 1941 le général dumas qui
dit beaucoup plus de choses sur ce
qu'est l'idéal républicain
le père d'alexandre celui dont
anatole-france disais et je vais dire le
mot parce qu'il montre combien notre
histoire est difficile anatole france
prix nobel de littérature disait le plus
grand des dumas c'est le fils de la
négresse anatole france
aujourd'hui le mot est impossible à
juste titre mais dans la bouche
d'anatole france c'est le plus bel
hommage républicain qu'on puisse faire
alors peut-être monsieur le sénateur si
vous le voulez nous pourrions vous et
moi
militer pour la reconstruction de la
statue du général du marché brichant
ce prêt ministre je vous ai demandé de
protéger les travaux des historiens et
leur capacité d'écrire histoire avec
l'esprit critique qui nous
caractéristiques qui nous caractérise
matt bloc rappelé qu'entre tous les
péchés regard d'une science du temps le
plus impardonnable et est l'imposition
on sait bien lui aujourd'hui qui est
utilisé par des minorités prête à de
réels autodafé au delà de ce cousin
d'ibm surpris ministre je vous exhorte à
ce que la réaction de la de l'exécutif
au-delà de ces contradictions soit la
hauteur des outrages fait à notre
histoire et aux femmes et aux hommes qui
ont bâti merci la parole est maintenant
à notre collègue benito guilbaud le
groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre j'associe à ma question les
commissaires socialistes de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
la crise sanitaire entraîner une
récession économique et social qui nous
oblige à repenser nos modèles de
consommation et de production alors que
les plans de relance ne cesse
d'inquiéter les entreprises et les
salariés dans leur visibilité parfois
complexes de nombreuses voix s'élèvent
pour demander que la sortie de crise de
2020 ne ressemble pas à celle de 2008
quand les programmes de soutien à
l'économie avait entraîné une hausse
significative des émissions de co2
certes il faut rapidement soutenir la
reprise d'activité et relancer l'emploi
mais ignoraient l'impérative nécessité
de construire dès aujourd'hui le projet
d'une économie verte serait
irresponsable
oui nous devons soutenir dans l'urgence
des secteurs de l'aéronautique et de
l'automobile
mais il faut mobiliser maintenant les
aides financières significatives et
engager rapidement une réflexion sur la
formation des salariés à de nouveaux
métiers pour réaliser avec succès le
verdissement de leur production hors
airbus envisage de couper dans son
budget recherche et développement et
dans la dope et dans la course à
l'hydrogène
l'allemagne n'a pas attendu pour
investir massivement dans l'hydrogène
vert de même nous devons construire une
politique volontariste de rénovation
thermique des bâtiments et des logements
que la ministre de la transition
écologique appelle d'ailleurs de ses
voeux et que le secteur du bâtiment est
prêt à mettre en oeuvre
enfin le temps est venu de développer
une politique des transports
écologique domaine dans lequel nous
accusons un retard un retard important
au regard des évolutions chez nos
voisins européens tandis que la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
s'apprête à rendre ces cinquante
propositions et que la commission
européenne souhaite une relance verte
pourvoyeuse d'emplois madame la ministre
pouvez vous nous préciser quels moyens
financiers efficient vous comptez engagé
pour accélérer la transition énergétique
et écologique dont le ministre de
l'économie a dit lui même que ce serait
une erreur historique que de l'ignorer
ou pour vous répondre la parole et
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances quand même
pas dire une hache et merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
tocqueville
vous l'avez dit il n'y a pas de grandes
économies sans grande industrie mais il
n'y a pas de grandes industries qui sera
durable si elle ne fait pas cette
transition écologique et énergétique
c'est ce qui nous anime et lorsque nous
avons travaillé sur le pacte productif
pacte productif dont les grands axes
étaient la décarbonation de l'économie
avec un travail très précis avec les
huit filières les plus émettrices en
termes d'activité le travail sur le
soutien à l'innovation et je pense à
tous les projets qui préfigure le
travail que nous allons faire sur
l'hydrogène les technologies vertes
le l'hydrogène notamment dans les
motorisations ferroviaire est
aujourd'hui ce qu'on est en train de
construire sur l'aéronautique
et puis le travail au niveau européen et
vous l'avez vu la france a non seulement
mobilisé ses partenaires mais elle a
obtenu que soit votée le green deal que
soit annoncée un mécanisme d'inclusion
carbone qui devrait prochainement
déboucher et que la finance verte
prennent une ampleur beaucoup plus
importante
cette relance verte elle est également
très largement au coeur des plans de
soutien que nous avons lancée muriel
pénicaud me souffle et cali travaillait
sur le plan compétences dans ses
négociations avec les organisations
syndicales
elle est également au coeur du plan
aéronautique puisque nous mobilisons
près d'un milliard cinq pour investir
sur les technologies vertes plutôt que
de changer des avions qui polluent
petit peu moins aujourd'hui et nous
avons travaillé dans le plan automobile
pour relocaliser près d'un milliard
d'euros d'investissements qui sont
uniquement orientée sur des
motorisations et des technologies vertes
avec l'objectif de produire près d'un
million de véhicules électriques d'ici
trois à quatre ans ça ce sont des
avancées qui sont majeurs enfin la
transition écologique énergétique sera
très clairement au coeur de notre plan
de relance nous ferons des annonces
fortes le président de la république a
tracé le chemin et que ce soit en
matière de rénovation thermique de
mobilité verte ou d'investissements au
service de l'industrie décarbonée nous
serons au rendez vous merci la parole
est maintenant notre collègue antoine le
faire pour le groupe l'est républicain
avec deux minutes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre la justice
elle sera simple et direct madame la
ministre mesurez vous sincèrement la
gravité de la situation des règlements
de comptes en plein centre ville
des bandes armées qui déferle pour
s'affronter une violence inédite qui
nargue la police et la justice
cela ne se déroule pas dans le chaos de
pays lointains mais bel et bien dans un
quartier d'une paisible ville de
province l'état n'apparaît assurément
plus assez fort pour y faire régner
l'ordre public la loi de la république
est supplantée par la loi du plus fort
et du plus violent
c'est la négation même de notre
civilisation le tribalisme qui a
remplacé la justice
l'impunité dans ces quartiers devenus la
règle et les témoignages de policiers
désespérée face à l'absence de paix nous
on prône au prononcé de peine symbolique
se multiplient mais il ya pire encore
que l'absence de paix nous la peine
symbolique il y à madame la ministre vo
récente décision qui constitue un
véritable blanc seing pour les voyous et
autres délinquants
après avoir procédé à près de 14 mai
libération dans l'eau prison pour cause
de crise sanitaire
vous avez diffusé le 20 mai une
circulaire afin de limiter au maximum
les incarcérations préférant ainsi
condamné les délinquants insolvable à
des peines d'amendé de la prison avec
sursis ou des travaux d'intérêt général
qui de toute façon ne seront jamais
exécuté il ya deux façons de lutter
contre la surpopulation des prisons en
construire de nouvelles promesses du
début du quinquennat passé aux
oubliettes où il est celle qui existe
quitte à se laisser aller à l'injustice
et à faire disparaître le sens même de
la
malheureusement vous avez choisi cette
deuxième solution qui s'accordent avec
votre conception de la justice
hélas impuissante pour éviter
l'embrasement du quartier des grésillés
vous préférez dicter aux juges le choix
de la peine en fonction des capacités
pénitentiaires
quelle justice voulez vous madame la
ministre pensez vous que le moment est
bien choisi pour mettre en oeuvre la
régulation carcéral que vous appelez de
vos voeux qui n'est plus ni plus ni
moins que l'institutionnalisation d'une
totale impunité est franchement le
moment de donner le signal que l'état
baissent les bras jusqu'à quel niveau de
violence faudra-t-il aller avant de
reconnaître que vous faites fausse route
je vous invite en conclusion à méditer
sur ces mots de charles péguy l'ordre et
l'ordre seul fut en définitive la
liberté le désordre fait la servitude
pour moi la parole et kavala de la gare
d'esbly de là vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames mais
c'est un triste messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur le faire je vous
répondrai en trois points d'abord les
mesures que nous avons adoptées pendant
la crise sanitaire avait exclusivement
une visée sanitaires il s'agissait
d'éviter la diffusion du virus dans ces
milieux fermés que constituent les
prisons nous avons bénéficié de la
faiblesse de la délinquance de rue
pendant la période du confinement d'une
part et d'autre part de mesures de
libération en fin de peine en toute fin
de peine pour un certain nombre de
détenus les deux mesures conjuguées ont
fait qu'effectivement il y a aujourd'hui
treize mille détenus en moins par
rapport aux chiffres du 16 mars
deuxième aspect de ma réponse monsieur
le sénateur je souhaite que nous
puissions conduire une politique pénale
volontaires claire et ferme
cette politique pénale elle se traduit
par le refus d'une loi d'aministie gelé
dit à plusieurs reprises alors que
beaucoup incité à prendre une loi
d'aministie je souhaite qu'il y ait
toujours des décisions individuelles
prises par des juges
deuxième élément qui est également très
très réelles et très puissant je n'ai
pas d'objectif chiffré
mon propos est celui du gouvernement est
de trouver des peines juste des peines
efficace des peines qui correspond à
l'infraction commise et à la
personnalité de celui qui a commis
l'infraction et d'ailleurs je dois dire
que les résultats délibérations qui ont
été prononcées de manière anticipée
pendant la crise sanitaire montre qu'il
y à peu d'échecs
nous n'avons eu qu'une trentaine de
réincarcération
alors qu'il y a eu six mille six cents
personnes qui ont été libérées de
manière anticipée avant la fin de la
peine ce n'est pas me semble-t-il la
traduction d'un échec de cette politique
troisième élément pour répondre à votre
question de manière très précise
troisième élément monsieur sénateurs il
ne faut pas faire d'amalgamé
ce serait une erreur est me semble-t-il
ce sont des propos qui ne doivent pas
être tenus dans cette assemblée ce qui
se passe à dijon est grave dramatique le
soutien doit être apportée aux forces de
l'ordre et il faut combattre les
personnes qui sont à l'origine de ces
violences
mais je vous ferai observé que sur les
personnes qui ont été gardés à vue
aucune ne sortait d'une incarcération
récente
aucune n'a beaucoup ici et donc des
libérations anticipées prises
précédemment
je crois qu'il ne faut pas faire
d'amalgamé c'est très important la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
line perreault pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole à gauche
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres ma question s'adresse à un
muriel pénicaud
madame la ministre nous ne mesurons pas
encore tous les impacts de cette crise
sanitaire
malgré tout les aides annoncées il faut
pourtant savoir qu'à cette période de
l'année beaucoup de nos jeunes jouent
leur avenir professionnel vous nous
annoncez vouloir relancer l'industrie
dans notre pays faire revenir de la
fabrication voilà plusieurs années que
l'apprentissage rencontrent des
difficultés de recrutement
nous devons nous repositionner ouvrir
les portes des cfa afin de valoriser les
métiers manuels revoir le coût d'un
apprenti re calculer le temps passé en
centre et le temps en entreprise
communiqué et innover les métiers
manuels n'attire plus alors que les
artisans sont en demande
ce type de formation ne doit plus être
considéré comme une voie de garage
lors de l'orientation scolaire
l'éducation nationale à la halle à un
rôle immense à jouer pour que le collège
oriente davantage vers les métiers
manuels
nos artisans ont façonné notre
patrimoine qu'il soit bâti cleanair
créatif pourtant ces métiers perdent peu
à peu de leur renommée
malgré les efforts des cfa et autres
structures de formation nous devons
revaloriser laisser happer combien de
pme sont la création d'hommes et de
femmes ne possédant que ce diplôme
n'oublions pas que l'artisanat est la
plus grande entreprise de france
cette crise a mis en difficultés toute
notre économie
les centres de formation s'inquiète pour
l'avenir
les entreprises seront elles au rendez
vous vous avez pris des mesures
importantes pour ces dernières que pour
que ces dernières incite les chefs
d'entreprise à embaucher des apprentis
et je vous en remercie
le gouvernement va-t-il aider
l'artisanat à retrouver la place qu'il
mérite et développer les valeurs de
l'apprentissage afin d'attirer les
élèves vers des études manuel pour vous
répondre la parole travail
j'avais la parole c'est le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
d'abord nous partageons une conviction
l'apprentissage est une voie
d'excellence une voie d'avenir
la moitié des artisans aujourd'hui on
était apprenti un jour et un tiers des
jeunes créer ou reprendre une entreprise
c'est un avenir vers l'emploi salarié
mais c'est aussi un vin nains à venir
d'entrepreneures c'est pour ça que nous
avons engagées toutes nos forces dans
cette bataille de cette réforme de
l'apprentissage et je dois dire que avec
+16 % constatée en février d'apprentis
près de 500000 apprentis des chiffres
historiques qu'on n'avait jamais connu
en france un rythme jamais connu on
pouvait dire qu'il y avait un engouement
y compris du côté des jeunes qui
commençaient à comprendre alors la bonne
nouvelle dont la difficulté
c'est qu'avec le ministre des questions
nationales la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur
nous avons mis aussi la possibilité de
dire qu'on voulait aller vers
l'apprentissage dans afin de n'être et
dans parcours et donc c'est la première
fois et au foie quoi on voit une demande
très forte des jeunes ils ont compris
ils ont compris les mesures ont été
prises aussi denise de l'éducation
nationale a par exemple changer les
règles pour les collèges en mettant sur
le même plan toutes les filières et ça
ça joue beaucoup évidemment dans le
conseil aux parents et aux jeunes
mais je crois que la dynamique qu'on
avait grâce à l'iphone
il faut pas la perdre pas la perdre au
moment où il ya toute une jeunesse qui
craint pour l'avenir c'est pour ça que
nous avons pris les mesures pour la
prime c'est aussi pour ça que nous avons
soutenu et maintenu le coup contrat
pendant toute la crise pour les centres
de formation d'apprentis financer des
développeurs de l'apprentissage permis
aux jeunes en situation de handicap
d'entrée aussi en apprentissage et
aujourd'hui nous avons maintenant une
plateforme commune nous nous connaissons
depuis quelques jours tous les jeunes
nominativement qui veulent entrer dans
l'apprentissage et nous allons pouvoir
avec les recteurs et préfets au niveau
départemental tous les bois vérifier que
les organisations professionnelles que
chaque jeune
chaque jeune qui veut en train d'un
portage est une chose dans la réforme
dans les mesures que nous avons prises
de façon très rapide il ya quelques
jours nous avons aussi décidé que la
somme de formation d'apprentis pourra
accueillir jusqu'à six mois un jeune qui
veut entre un apprentissage qui n'a pas
encore tout à fait les acquis ou les
codes de l'entreprise ou le contrat
d'apprentissage pour l'aider à trouver
cette jonction
oui dans notre démarche de l'emploi des
jeunes que nous concertons aujourd'hui
est que les partenaires sociaux une des
grandes priorités sera l'apprentissage
nous avions réussi il faut continuer
vous réussir pour notre jeunesse merci
la parole et peuvent leur collègue
jérôme bascher pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
monsieur mise à l'intérieur quoi qu'il
vous en coûte l'autorité de l'état est
malmené
malgré la brillante tirade de monsieur
le premier ministre et la leçon
édifiante de roger karoutchi l'autorité
républicaine est malmené par la violence
elle est malmenée par le mépris des
forces de l'ordre mais elle est
également malmené par des comportements
qui substitue la tambouille électorale
au respect des principes démocratiques
ce n'est pas la règle qui doit
vous tenir c'est à vous de tenir la
règle il ya de démocratie que si les
élections se tiennent à des dates fixes
et régulière alors que les élections
régionales sont prévues en mars 2021
les raisons annoncées d'un report de
plus d'un an laisse perplexe inaugurant
la date d'élections pour convenance
personnelle au mieux pour convenance de
la république en marche au pire selon la
presse le président de la république
descendant du grenier à la cave se
serait livré à une tractations de
marchands de tapis avec les présidents
de région je cite je vous aide
financièrement si vous m'aidez à
reporter les régionales après la
présidentielle car j'ai des opposants
politiques parmi vous aurait il déclaré
ajoutant je ne vais pas donner de
l'argent à mes adversaires
on apprend que le président de la
république à des adversaires il donc pas
le président de tous les français
considérant que l'argent public des
régions est le sien et que du fait du
prince
il distribue à qui bon lui semble comme
le disait xavier bertrand derrière les
élections il ya le peuple et le peuple
on le respecte alors monsieur le
ministre
allez vous renoncer à cette manoeuvre
grossière allez vous travailler avec
tous tes région élu démocratiquement et
dans la compétence légitime elle
développement économique pour vous
répondre la parole les communistes de
l'inter président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur permettez
moi d'avoir une petite pensée sur ce
qu'est être républicain et elle sera
très personnelle ou m'interroger sur les
élections régionales
je sais monsieur le sénateur ce qu'est
être républicain pour préserver
justement la république et faire en
sorte que dans ma région
ce soit un président les républicains
qui soit élu parce que je sais aussi ne
pas me tromper de combat et de la même
façon monsieur le sénateur ce que je
sais c'est qu'il vaut mieux certainement
écouté l'actuel président de la région
provence alpes côte d'azur
monsieur renaud muselier qui a contesté
les fêtes que vous avez évoquées qui a
contesté ces paroles et qui les a
démenties alors je nous invite à rester
sur l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est quoi
monsieur le sénateur ça n'est pas ce qui
a été rapporté par la presse
l'essentiel c'est votre conclusion et je
la rejoins parfaite
bon c'est justement de cette compétence
économique majeur qu'exercent les
collectivités locales et les régions en
particulier et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut réécouter le président
de la république et non pas lui prêter
quelques propos dimanche il a dit qu'il
y avait deux priorités
la première c'est celle de la relance
économique et social de notre pays nous
en avons parlé vous êtes engagés sur ces
sujets je le sais et il a évoqué un
deuxième chantier majeur celui d'un
nouveau partage territorial des
compétences et des pouvoirs celui de
savoir s'appuyer sur les collectivités
locales qui font les actions notamment
économiques
et comme vous je pense aux épaules
conseils régionaux il a évoqué cela avec
deux présidents de région dont le
président de l'association des régions
de france et sera la réalité et si nous
franchissons cette étape une nouvelle
étape de décentralisation
il n'est pas illégitime de discuter avec
les présidents de région de la meilleure
façon de les accompagner dans
l'opérationnalité concrètes dollar
action pour défendre l'économie dans nos
territoires et relancer l'emploi partout
c'est nécessaire et en même temps de
discuter avec elle s'il ya une réforme
en profondeur de quel est le bon moment
pour la mettre en place un seul objectif
monsieur le sénateur ne pas empêcher
l'action de la relance économique par
des élections il est légitime que ces
discussions puissent avoir lieu avec les
présidents élus ou en fonction dans nos
régions c'est cela la réalité ne
qualifiait pas cela de tambouille
il s'agit au contraire d'un dialogue
démocratique rf aux concurrents il est
important que nous lui posions tous
ensemble sans arrière pensée sur la
table je vous remercie
je me sers pour quelques secondes en
cette veille du 18 juin je vous invite à
ne pas capituler sur la démocratie
et je vous rappelle à ce triptyque
historique pour gouverner la france
l'honneur le bon sens l'intérêt
supérieur de la patrie c'est vrai n'est
pas le général qui veut de volts qui
veut merci
la parole est à notre collègue frédéric
marchand pour le groupe de la république
en barges
merci monsieur le président madame
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
nous connaissons une crise sanitaire
sans précédent qui a remis sur le devant
de la scène le plus vieux sujet du monde
celui de l'alimentation et de ses
acteurs durement éprouvé ce sont nombre
de filières agricoles partout dans notre
pays qui sont particulièrement touchés
par la crise sanitaire économique du
coït 19
il conviendra d'ailleurs de tirer les
leçons de cette crise pour retrouver ce
que la fnsea et bien d'autres appellent
une souveraineté alimentaire solidaire
qui devra associer préalable
indispensable
tous les acteurs publics et privés et
s'appuyer sur une logique d'alimentation
durable et local
je sais que le président de la
république vous même et le gouvernement
fait une priorité dans le cadre de la
relance placée sous le signe de la
transition écologique une crise sans
précédent disait j'ai qui n'a pas
épargné un seul secteur avec notamment
des cours de matières premières
agricoles qui ne savait plus où donner
de la tête
en raison de la fermeture des
restaurants hôtels cantine et autres
lieux de convivialité à la française
nous pouvons collectivement nous
féliciter que l'état était au rendez
vous de la solidarité en direction de
nos filières au travers de mécanismes
financiers de dispositifs visant à
passer au mieux cette épreuve
j'en veux pour preuve les décisions et
les moyens mis en place pour les
filières de la pêche et de l'aquaculture
viticoles ou bien encore horticole
monsieur le ministre vous connaissez
bien le département du nord pour y être
venu à plusieurs reprises terre de
labeur
c'est aussi un grenier d'abondance pour
notre pays tout entier alors je voudrais
ici devant vous évoquez deux filières
essentiel dans notre économie nationale
terriblement impactés par cette crise
celle de la pomme de terre et les
surplus aujourd'hui estimé à plus de 450
milles tonnes et l'absence de
perspectives s'agissant des débouchés je
voudrais aussi attirer votre attention
sur le marché de la bière qui devraient
reculer d'au moins 30 à 40% cette année
en france en raison de la fermeture
heureusement désormais levée des lieux
de consommation hors domicile pommes de
terre et bière vous le savez sont deux
marqueurs forts de notre identité
départementale mais aussi nationale ma
question monsieur le ministre sera donc
simple
pouvez vous nous dire si l'état seront
au rendez vous pour sortir ces deux
filières de l'ornière dans laquelle elle
se trouve et préparer l'avenir merci
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur didier guillot
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur cher frédéric
marchand oui je crois que en termes
d'agriculture
le gouvernement est au rendez vous
durant cette crise mais surtout ceux qui
ont été au rendez vous c'est les femmes
et les hommes de la 2e ligne
ce sont les agricultures aux reculs
tristes qui ont travaillé sans cesse
sans relâche pour produire et pour
alimenter nos concitoyens ce sont les
entreprises de l'agroalimentaire sont
les coopératives agricoles les
transformateurs qui sont image tout le
territoire national qui ont été présents
qui ont travaillé parfois dans des
conditions difficiles et d'absentéisme
pour faire en sorte que la chaîne
alimentaire tienne et c'est enfin les
distributeurs les femmes et des hommes
qui sont dans les caisses qui ont les
rayons qui ont bienveillant et qui ont
travaillé sans cesse dès le début pour
faire en sorte que les françaises et des
français puissent manger la chaîne
alimentaire a tenu parce que la chaîne
alimentaire était soutenu le
gouvernement immédiatement a pris des
mesures pour toutes les entreprises
françaises et toutes les entreprises
agricoles toutes les entreprises de la
chaîne alimentaire ont pu avoir accès à
l'ensemble de ces mesures transversales
le chômage partiel les fonds de garantie
je n'y reviens pas mais spécifiquement
nous avons essayé de répondre aux
demandes des filières qui ont beaucoup
souffert
certaines ont beaucoup souffert tout
simplement parce qu'avec les arrêtés de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
elles ont elles ont été la conséquence
de la fermeture des chrd hôtel
restaurant est évidemment celle ci nous
sommes allés directement les aider
notamment sur l'horticulture et sur la
viticulture qui a beaucoup souffert
nous avons essayé de travailler avec
l'europe sur des mesures de marché et
nous avons obtenu mais pas
particulièrement sur les deux filières
que vous évoquez le gouvernement a
souhaité des idées directement la pomme
de terre industrielle évidemment les
frites les restaurants rapides les
restaurants les cantines la restauration
scolaire c'est là on en mange beaucoup
nous avons une mesure de marché
spécifique pour les aider et comme la
bière qui est un dégât collatéral là
aussi parce que les grands festivals
parce que les théâtres parce que les les
fêtes n'ont pas eu lieu et une aide
spécifique à au bras à la filière
brassicole a été alloué oui monsieur le
sénateur
gouvernement je pense a été au rendez
vous des filières agricoles pour une
alimentation saine sûr et durable et
pour travailler la souveraineté
alimentaire je vous remercie
merci la parole et à notre collègue
cédric perrin pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités de
la santé l'hôpital public est en crise
les soignants souffre vous avez engagé
le ségur de la santé pour répondre à ces
difficultés le président de la
république a promis un système plus
souple plus simple plus en proximité en
revalorisant le collectif le sens de
l'équipe et l'initiative des
professionnels
l'ouverture de ce chantier s'imposait
c'était une excellente nouvelle
trois semaines après son lancement il
nous en nous aspire pourtant quelques
inquiétudes majeures
le gouvernement est absent de la table
des négociations les syndicats
d'infirmiers n'y étais même pas convié
le doute parcours de très nombreuses
organisations syndicales
toutes dénoncent des sujets escamoté et
craignent que les arbitrages soient déjà
réalisés elles redoutent un simulacre de
concertation pour calmer leur colère
grande foutaise selon certains
urgentistes le ségur suscite l'hostilité
de tous les soignants qui manifestaient
partout en france hier
monsieur le ministre la guerre de guerre
lasse les soignants attendent des
garanties des garanties financières bien
sûr mais pas seulement
il faut des garanties quant aux
conditions de travail il faut des
garanties sur la question des effectifs
hospitaliers
il faut des garanties sur la formation
et la recherche médicale qui doivent
être liés aux soins pour préparer nos
soignants aux métiers de demain
il faut des garanties pour refaire de la
france un pays leader en matière de
prévention et de soins
il faut des garanties quant à la place
qu'occuperont les territoires dans la
direction les la direction des soins
les chefs de service les médecine la
médecine de ville les ars les chu ou
encore l'hôpital privé
si l'on ne rompt pas avec le fléau
bureaucratique la centralisation de la
décision le cloisonnement des structures
et bien l'augmentation des salaires
soulagement
soulagera momentanément la douleur sans
soigner le mal profond
alors monsieur le ministre entendez-vous
enfin adopté une méthode réel de
concertation appuyé sur les territoires
et sur les soignants merci pour vous
répondre la parole et à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la sorte et vous avez la
parole
alors mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
cédric perrin vous l'avez dit il des
manifestations hier ont eu lieu et je
crois que c'est aussi le symbole de ce
qu'attendent de l'ensemble des soignants
de ce qu'ils ont pu vivre le temps de la
crise c'est pour ça que le président de
la république et le premier ministre se
sont exprimés se sont engagés à
travailler sur la revalorisation et
surtout revendications salariales
qu'il s'agisse du secteur hospitalier
hospitalier mais aussi du secteur médico
social notamment par le biais d épargne
parce que c'est un ensemble et c'est
face à cet ensemble face aux crises
depuis plusieurs années notre système
hospitalier de ce qu'ont vécu et si
notre système de santé a tenu face au
coc u19 c'est aussi parce que les
soignants était bien l'un était bien
présent avec des coopérations qui était
sans précédent quand on parle hôpital
public hôpital privé quand on parle
médecine de ville l'hôpital quand on
parle de le lever des lourdeurs qui ont
pu se faire grâce à de l'indre et du
dialogue et qui jusqu'à présent n'avait
pas lieu et c'est bien dans un seul
objectif c'est bien de soigner et de
sauver nos nos concitoyens et c'est dans
ce cadre là que segura été lancé par le
premier ministre le ministre de la santé
pour pouvoir concertée et cette carte
sans concertation nous on veut rapide
parce que la réponse doit être apportée
rapidement c'est une nécessité c'est une
demande des soignants nécessité de
l'ensemble du système de santé
c'est pour ça que les consultations sont
en cours elles sont rapides juillet avec
les premières propositions mi juillet
près de 300 acteurs autour de la table
qui vont des médecins qu'ils aillent des
infirmiers l'ensemble des participants
sont présents 300 acteurs autour de la
table avec des groupes de travail
thématiques quatre piliers thématique la
rurbanisation et un temps spécifique aux
six décès au territoire sur lequel
organisations sont en cours sur
l'ensemble des territoires pour que les
bonnes pratiques de la gestion de la
crise du coc vide puisse remonter puisse
nous apporter des solutions et c'est
l'objectif du ségur et les conclusions
seront apportés mi juillet vous
remercier merci la parole les bateaux
d'autres collègues en congé le prix
ville
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mais madame et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues longtemps
l'école de la république fut notre
fierté
un levier puissant de l'ascenseur social
mais les classements de l' ocde sont
désormais des constats douche froide et
ce année après année le niveau des
élèves n'est pas la hauteur de nos
espérances notamment en terme
d'autonomie et des inégalités scolaires
fortement liées aux origines sociales la
crise sanitaire est arrivé et n'a rien
arrangé
nous avons perdu beaucoup trop d'élèves
certes monsieur le ministre la
communication sur les vacances
apprenantes va bon train laissant croire
que tout est sous contrôle mais quelle
sera l'ampleur de ce dispositif
touchera-t-il tous les élèves qu'il
faudrait quand dans le même temps la
mesure exceptionnelle du 22 mars de
cette année de 50 % de crédits d'impôt
accordés pour les cours privés à
distance permettait déjà aux familles
aisées un accompagnement de leurs
enfants pendant le confinement
l'école est gratuite et obligatoire et
doit le rester elle doit être la même
pour tous et doit permettre à tout
enfant de france de devenir ce qu'il
peut devenir
c'est à dire lui permettre de déployer
tous ses talents c'est votre devoir est
votre responsabilité que cela soit le
confinement s'il a été difficile pour
tout le monde l'a été encore plus pour
certains je pense au maire sans aucun
autre équipement numérique qu'un simple
téléphone portable je parle de mère au
foyer bien sûr je vous laisse imaginer
la gestion de la gestion rien qu'avec
deux enfants s'ajoute à cela à l'électro
nisme qui frappent 13 millions de
français la fracture sociale est en
train de devenir un gouffre béant
gouverner c'est anticiper et prévoir ma
question au nom du groupe socialiste et
républicain porte sur la rentrée
scolaire de septembre cruciales comme
jamais quelle est votre stratégie face à
l'urgence absolue
quelles dispositions spécifiques seront
prises concrètement afin de remédier au
creusement des inégalités scolaires et
numérique durant la crise et de
permettre à tous les jeunes en âge
scolaire de reprendre le chemin de
l'école sans souffrir de retard
irrécupérable je remercie
on vous répondra par les communistes de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse sur
michel blanquer parole merci le monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs même la sénatrice préville
je fais un rêve ce rêve serait celui
d'une unité nationale autour de l'école
de la république de façon à ne pas
noircir le tableau et au contraire à
tracer ensemble des chemins qui peuvent
être commun puisque nous voulons tous la
même chose c'est-à-dire la hausse du
niveau général et la justice sociale et
donc c'est vrai vous avez raison de le
dire que dans les classement ocde la
france n'a pas eu des performances
extraordinaires ces dernières années
mais il est important aussi de souligner
les éléments d'espoir les éléments de
levier dans ce que nous faisons par
exemple les récentes évaluations de cp
et de ce1 qui montre que nous sommes sur
une voie de progrès pour nos élèves a
fortiori dans les territoires les plus
en difficulté ou trois cent mille
enfants bénéficient du dispositif de
dédoublement des classes de cp et de ce1
ces mêmes trois cent mille enfants qui
ont pu rentrer prioritairement par
rapport aux autres depuis le 11 mai
puisque précisément ils sont dans des
classes de 12
au début c'était plus nombreux parce que
c'est vrai c'est dans les classes
sociales les plus défavorisées qu'on a
eu le plus de mal à faire revenir les
enfants mais ils étaient 30 % le 11 mai
ils sont aujourd'hui près de 60 % et
j'espère qu'ils seront au delà de 80 %
d'ici à la fin du mois donc il ya des
efforts qui sont faits pour la justice
sociale bien sûr pendant le confinement
il ya eu 150 mille élèves qui pendant
les vacances de printemps ont fait
l'objet d'un d'une aide personnalisée et
je pourrais vous citer mille choses que
nous avons faites pour la justice
sociale et regardez regardez dans le
futur la comparaison européenne qui sera
fait entre la france et les autres pays
en matière éducative sur l'enseignement
à distance sur l'accueil des enfants de
personnel soignant et vous n'aurez pas à
rougir
alors oui il ya des dégâts sociaux du
déconfinement et c'est bien pour ça que
j'étais l'avocat le militant d'un
déconfinement scolaire pour lequel nous
avons été très critiquée avec le
président de la république il ya à peine
plus d'un mois pour lesquels maintenant
tout le monde voit bien que c'est est ce
qu'il ya à faire
tant et si bien qu'aujourd'hui on nous
demande d'aller plus vite et plus loin
alors nous préparons la rentrée scolaire
dans la concertation ce moment même avec
toutes les organisations syndicales dans
dix jours
il aura la circulaire de rentrée keira
dans votre sens c'est à dire le sens que
vous avez indiquée sur lui de la justice
sociale
celui du rattrapage pour les élèves qui
ont le plus de difficulté préville vous
avez quelques secondes qui nous
souhaiter
merci beaucoup pour votre réponse
monsieur le ministre alors jeu il y a
effectivement un engagement un
engagement très important à prendre de
la part de toute la communauté éducative
et vous pouvez compter évidemment sur
les professeurs et notamment peut-être
de mettre l'accent sur l'autonomie et la
confiance en soi et le développement
cognitif des enfants de façon à ce
qu'ils s'épanouissent le mieux possible
merci merci nous en avons terminé mes
chers collègues avec les questions
gouvernement merci monsieur le premier
ministre
mesdames et messieurs des ministres les
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu mercredi 24 juin à 15 heures je
vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h35 pour l'examen du projet
de loi organique portant report des
élections sénatoriales des élections
législatives partielles
la séance est suspendue et voilà pour
cette séance de questions d'actualité du
sénat au gouvernement où il a beaucoup
été question des tensions et des
violences actuellement dans la société
française et pour en parler j'accueille
le président du groupe l'est républicain
au sénat bruno retailleau bonjour
bonjour à vous alors on l'a vu hier
notamment dans la manifestation
hospitalière il ya beaucoup de violence
on l'a vu ces derniers jours à dijon
comment vous expliquer ces violences
actuelles dans la société française
c'est l'échec c'est l'échec de la
politique des mails macron c'est l'échec
parce que on a organisé une forme
d'impunité quand on voit par exemple que
pendant le confinement et sous prétexte
du confinement
la ministre de la justice a libéré
quatorze mille détenus qu'elle a fait le
20 mai une circulaire pour décourager
l'emprisonnement en réalité madame bello
baisser la continuation de madame
taubira madame taubira en avait rêvé
madame b loubet le fait et on l'a bien
vu aussi l'acte fondateur finalement du
quinquennat monsieur macron c'était la
décision sur notre dame des landes où
une hyper violence a réussi à faire
fléchir l'état on a donné raison au
chantage à la violence et qui s'aiment
évidemment le désordre récolte la
violence et pourtant si on prend
l'exemple des black blocs qui était
présent dans la manifestation hier et
bien les responsables politiques ont
fait des lois vous avez d'ailleurs été
l'auteur de deux textes sur sur ces
black bloc et on voit que ça ne marche
pas ce n'est pas efficace si ça peut
tout à fait fonctionner puisque le texte
que nous avions initiée ça permet de
condamner des délits notamment pour ceux
qui se cachent derrière des masques qui
se cache notamment derrière des cagoules
voilà simplement ce que je constate
c'est que quand on a un ministre de
l'intérieur ministre de la justice qui
désavouent leurs troupes qui abandonne
les forces de police ou de gendarmerie
il faut pas s'étonner que les
délinquants s'en sortent finalement et
se sentent renforcés
alors parlons des violences à dijon
qu'on a vu ces derniers jours avec un
affrontement entre la communauté
tchétchène et les habitants du quartier
des grésillés à dijon
est ce qu'il y a eu un laxisme d'état
comme le dit marine le pen avec une
faille des forces de l'ordre pour réagir
à temps assez violente et il ya bien sûr
un sentiment d'impunité
quand certains parlent de violence
policiers
c'est tout simplement pour déconsidérer
la gendarmerie pour déconsidérer aussi
la police et on voit bien que désormais
la police la gendarmerie ne peuvent même
plus aller dans certains quartiers c'est
une impunité qu'on a totalement organisé
et la france s'est livré désormais au
tribalisme et donc il faut réagir et
quand le chef de l'état en réalité dit
que en tout cas l'elysée dit que ces
gens là les réfugiés qui ont commis des
fautes seraient expulsés c'est fou parce
que pour expulser des réfugiés en france
il faut des condamnations très grave ils
font que par exemple on est atteint la
sûreté de l'état par exemple pour le
terrorisme ou qu'on a écopé d'une peine
ferme de prison de dix années donc il ya
très peu d'exclusion et moi ce que je
propose que je vais proposer dans les
jours prochains
c'est une proposition de loi qu'on
modifie la loi pour faire en sorte que
ces gens auxquels la france finalement
donne sa générosité tend la main et qui
sont réfugiés dans notre prix lorsqu'ils
ne respectent pas la loi notre loi
républicaine et bien c'est dehors ça
voudrait dire baisser le seuil de
sanctions pour bien sûr elle serait le
seuil 10 écoutez on les tue 10 mais il
n'est pas question que la république
restent désarmés vis-à-vis de celle des
de ce qu'elle accueille généreusement
sur son territoire et qui lui font un
pied de nez et qui ne respectent pas ses
lois
sénant ses moeurs vous parliez de
tribalisme dans les quartiers l'ancien
premier ministre manuel valls
aujourd'hui à évoquer et bien une guerre
des races qui remplacerait la lutte des
classes est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse
mais effectivement effectivement en
france malheureusement il y à un racisme
aujourd'hui il y à un racisme un
antiracisme qui veut racisées les
rapports sociaux
il ya une mouvance des colonialistes il
ya une mouvance qui est une mouvance
aussi indigéniste qui voudrait
finalement aboutir à ce qu'il ya une
forme de prise de conscience raciale
dans la société française en opposant
les dominés et les dominants les noirs
et les blancs les jaunes et je ne sais
pas et ça c'est contraire à notre modèle
républicain
on est français parce que on n'est pas
de telle ou telle couleur de peau mais
parce qu'on partage un héritage parce
que il ya un projet en commun
et ça il faut absolument le rappeler
justement ces divisions dans la société
française dont il a beaucoup été
question dans cette séance cet après
midi est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle ne
s'explique pas aussi par des inégalités
sociales des inégalités de traitement
entre les citoyens
c'est le communautarisme ce qui explique
en réalité la tribalisation s'est
fracturé là c'est tout simplement qu' il
ya un certain nombre de groupuscules et
notamment l'ultra gauche mais d'autres
mouvances comme je l'expliquais ya
quelques instants qui veulent
communautariser la société française qui
veulent fracturé le modèle républicain
et il faut à tout prix s'opposer très
bien merci beaucoup
bruno retailleau d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et je vais maintenant
accueillir le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer
bonjour monsieur le ministre alors nous
allons parler bien du retour à l'école
obligatoire pour tous les élèves dans
les écoles et les collèges à partir du
22 juin
où en es et bien la modification du
protocole sanitaire dans les
établissements scolaires voilà on n'a
pas encore ce protocole alors le
protocole va diffuser dans les
prochaines heures donc aujourd'hui
mercredi il va dans le sens d'un
allègement et donc ça va faciliter aussi
la la préparation des choses pour les
acteurs je voudrais d'ailleurs les
remercier les directeurs d'école les
professeurs les inspecteurs principaux
de collège les professeurs aussi ont eu
beaucoup de travail les collectivités
locales
mais c'était pour la bonne cause comme
on dit c'était pour se dé confinement
progressif qui mêlait à la fois le
volontarisme c'est à dire faire revenir
les élèves et en même temps la prudence
parce qu'on doit évidemment faire encore
attention aux enjeux sanitaires
donc il ya plusieurs sujets dans
l'allègement du protocole sanitaire mais
le principal chacun sait c'est celui la
distanciation physique donc les grandes
règles qui seront par écrit dans le
protocole sanitaire qui sera reçu par
tous les acteurs tout à l'heure c'est
d'une part le fait que à l'école
maternelle et à l'école élémentaire pour
qu'à l'école maternelle
vous n'avez plus de distanciation
physique c'est la même règle pour les
crèches par réalisme parce qu'on sait
que c'est pas ça n'est pas facile de
faire respecter cette distanciation
physique et puis parce que le conseil
scientifique nous disait que pour cet
âge là on peut si on peut faire ça
d'après les données que nous avons à
l'école élémentaire c'est à ses voisins
puisque l'idée c'est qu'on essaye de
faire respecter un m
mais il ya certaines classes ou quand on
recevra tous les élèves parfois on sera
obligé d'avoir un peu moins d'un mètre
donc c'est possible à l'école à l'école
élémentaire et puis au collège la
distance d'un mètre doit être respectée
et quand ça n'est pas possible parfois
pour des raisons physiques locales
alors il doit le port du masque est
obligatoire pour les collégiens lorsque
cette distance n'a mètres mais n'est pas
possible sur le plan latéral voilà
l'essentiel de l'allègement sur plan de
la distance physique
après il ya d'autres sujets beaucoup de
choses sont maintenus le fait de se
laver les mains
les gestes barrière toutes ces choses
qui au fond sont naturels aujourd'hui
dans notre vie quotidienne et et qui
font partie aussi finalement de
l'éducation à l'hygiène et à la santé
que nous développons chez les enfants ce
moment alors concernant ce nouveau
protocole sanitaire
et bien tout à l'heure sur le plateau de
public sénat on avait un débat avec
notamment des représentants des
enseignants qui disait d'ici le 22 juin
nous ne serons pas prêts pour appliquer
ce nouveau protocole qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez si nous serons prêts
l'ensemble de l'institution sera prête
bien sûr c'est une étape supplémentaire
avec du travail supplémentaire mais là
en l'occurrence
les règles de distanciation physique
font que ce sera ce sera faisable
ceux qui vous ont dit cela l'on dit
aussi sans se connaître la nouvelle
nature du protocole sanitaire très bien
merci beaucoup
jean michel blanquer pour votre
intervention je rappelle que vous nous
avez donné et bien les premières pistes
du nouveau protocole sanitaire dans les
écoles à partir du 22 juin je vais
maintenant accueillir le sénateur les
républicains des hauts-de-seine
roger karoutchi pour revenir un peu sur
l'essentiel de cette série de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement où il a
beaucoup été question est bien des
violences dans la société française de
la fin de l'unité nationale bonjour
roger karoutchi
alors comment vous expliquez bien ces
tensions qui ont vraiment augmenté juste
à la sortie de cette crise sanitaire
dans la société
d'abord parce que la crise sanitaire a
un peu fait comme l'effet d'un un
coussin si je peux dire sur la crise
sociale qui est préexister la sphère des
gilets jaunes les grandes grèves dans
les transports de la fin 2019 pro bien
que l'état du pays n'est pas bon qui
plus est sa rajouter dans la violence
permis à beaucoup de de gens comment
dire
assia liste indigéniste ultra
communautariste de jouer beaucoup
pendant la période de confinement et ça
s'est expliquée exprimé de manière
violente à la fin du confinement
il ya des maladresses du gouvernement
mais il ya aussi beaucoup de tensions
dans la société française et si le
gouvernement ne s'appuie pas clairement
complètement sur la police et la
gendarmerie va le système ne tient pas
alors roger karoutchi vous avez tout à
l'heure interrogé le premier ministre
sur cette question des tensions dans la
société et il vous a répondu sur et bien
un problème de respect de l'autorité de
l'état
on va l'écouter je vous fait réagir
d'air l'autorité de l'état
c'est la capacité monsieur le sénateur à
faire respecter la loi c'est la loi qui
doit prévaloir dans un état de droit
c'est la loi qui doit prévaloir dans la
république la loi et on voit bien que la
force parfois la met en cause on voit
bien que telle ou telle bande que tel ou
tel groupe parfois que tel ou tel
individu veut la faire
c'est des voeux la brise et veulent à
remettre en cause ce n'est pas un combat
récent vous savez bien monsieur le
sénateur c'est un combat éternel mais
c'est un combat qui aujourd'hui dans
notre pays se pose avec peut-être encore
plus d'acuité qu'il ne s'est posé dans
les années qui précèdent et l'autorité
de l'état qui est mise en péril par
telle ou telle bande ce sont les mots du
premier ministre est ce que justement ce
manque d'autorité de l'état il n'est pas
causée par l'absence des forces de
l'ordre dans certains quartiers dans
certaines villes reconnaissons que
l'affaiblissement l'autorité de l'état
ne date pas d'hier
ça fait des années qu'il ya des zones de
non-droit qu'il ya des compromissions
des facilités d'un certain quartiers
pour éviter les crises pour éviter les
difficultés et qu'on n'a pas toujours
voulu imposer l'ordre républicain
partout soit disant pour éviter les
tensions et ben maintenant ça nous
explose à la figure et ça nous explose à
la figure à tous les niveaux ultra
communautariste racialiste qui remettent
en cause bien des choses par rapport à
ce qu'est l'identité la nation française
avec la difficulté d'un gouvernement et
d'un premier ministre dont je partage
les propos mais à qui je pourrai dire
mettez vos actes en conformité alors
parce que les propos sont bien les ceux
du président la république dimanche soir
soutient la police à jean marie très
bien mais alors qu'en réalité ça se
fasse et qu'on ne remette pas en cause
systématiquement le collectif police
gendarmerie il peut y avoir des actes
personnels à arrimer mais en tout cas la
police et la gendarmerie sont des
piliers de la république
les déclarations c'est bien les accepte
encore mieux merci beaucoup
roger karoutchi d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et âme je vais vous redonner
la parole pour et bien votre débriefing
de cette séance de questions d'actualité
en plateau
oui merci beaucoup alexandre
effectivement on va bientôt commencer ce
débris mais vous allez
être dans un instant avec d'autres
sénateurs notamment le sénateur claude
malhuret
le président du groupe les indépendants
qui lui aussi va venir à votre micro
mais d'abord on va ré écouter et bien un
passage de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement qui vous
l'avez dit a été très largement
consacrée à la question des violences
des violences notamment dans les
quartiers le gouvernement a été
interpellé sur et bien les événements de
dijon à ce propos on va écouter bien
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur tout à l'heure j'ai échangé
avec le préfet je lui ai demandé de
piloter personnellement la situation
pour faire en sorte qu' il n'y ait pas
ces échauffourées
je dirais bande contrebande et encore je
ne sais pas si on peut qualifier comme
ça cette horde de sauvages totalement
insupportable vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice
il n'est pas question qu'il y ait un
mètre carré dans notre pays où la
république recule y compris face à ces
violences extrêmes et nous devons faire
en sorte que signé nulle part d' état de
non droit et que l'état soit toujours
présent pour juguler jubilé ces dérives
totalement insupportable totalement
inacceptable et le phénomène de violence
qu'a connu dijon pendant quatre jours
même si la nuit dernière les choses
étaient apaisées et malgré cela j'ai
demandé au préfet que près de 200 hommes
femmes la gendarmerie de la police 13
présente je demandais que la berri et
que le raid reste présent aussi dans les
jours qui viennent et ils reviendront en
tant que de besoin
tout comme j'ai demandé aussi à nos
services de police de veillée sous
l'autorité du ministère de la justice à
ce que l'identification des auteurs de
ces exactions commises dès samedi se
poursuivent et qui est des recherches
individuelles pour qu'ils ne soient pas
laissés libres l'idée qu'il serait
impunis ils ne seront pas impunis
madame la sénatrice vous l'avez dit nos
forces de sécurité intérieure ont
répondu elles ont rendu avec
l'engagement elles ont répondu avec le
courage et elle mérite pour cela d'être
salué je sais l'émotion je la partage ce
qui s'est passé est inacceptable
il est insupportable et sachez que où
que ce soit en france nous ferons
reculer ces pratiques de voyous
ces pratiques de voyous voilà pour sa
terre d'invention du ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner on va
débriefer cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement avec deux
invités sur ce plateau christian cambon
bonjour bonjour sénateurs l ère du val
de marne et président de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées merci beaucoup d'être
sur ce plateau est avec nous racheter
mal un jour bonjour sénateur ps du
val-d'oise et vous membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées
christian cambon qu'est-ce que vous
inspirent ces événements de dijon et la
réponse de christophe castaner le
gouvernement mise en accusation par
certains at il été à la hauteur on a
entendu aussi le problème le
renseignement territoriales qui a dû
manquer dans cette situation d'abord sur
les événements stupéfaction et colère
stupéfaction parce que ça s'est passé à
dijon et que pour nous dijon c'est la
france calme la france provinciale qui
montrent souvent du doigt du reste qui
se passe dans les grandes agglomérations
et là c'est à dijon c'est à dire un lieu
que nous n'attendions pas pour ce genre
de manifestation colère parce que les
images qui sont passés en vous que sur
les réseaux sont absolument scandaleuse
et effrayante voilà des voilà des hommes
et des femmes peut-être lui n'en sais
rien
qui est résident sur le territoire
français et qui sont équipés d'armes de
guerre et qui les utilise est ce si
effectivement sans qu'on ait pu
percevoir
la situation de ces communautés
notamment la communauté tchétchène dont
on a dit des services de renseignements
sur cette situation précise pour vous
pour l'instant les événements sont
suffisamment récent pour qu' on n'est
pas encore la clé sur ce plan mais nous
avons bien l'intention de comprendre
comment se fait-il qu'une telle
communauté aussi belliqueuse aussi armé
aussi violente peut se trouver sur le
territoire et se livrer à de telles
exactions
en tous les cas je pense que c'est une
émotion et une colère qui font que les
mots aujourd'hui du ministre vienne
j'allais dire heureusement calmer un
petit peu les choses mais comme cela a
été dit par mes collègues précédents ce
sont les actes maintenant qu'ils
conviennent de prendre lé parole et il
ya les actes rachid est mal on entend
aussi à droite que s'ouvre maintenant un
débat sur la question du droit d'asile
on a entendu à bruno retailleau aussi
commencé à s'exprimer sur ce sujet
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
non moi je vais dire est également la
seule faction et on va dire l'europe des
images qu'on a pu voir et surtout penser
aux populations qui ont vécu ces quatre
jours d'extrême violence également moi
j'ai eu mon t'aimons je veux dire mon
camarade et surtout mon ami françois
rebsamen au téléphone et j'ai pu mesurer
d'ailleurs tout le travail qui a été
fait par les locaux
et lui il a suivi la demande et des
forces de police sinaï dont il faut
aussi noter celle qu'il y avait un
manque de forces de police et de
sécurité sous ses vêtements l'a ensuite
je crois qu'il faut faire attention
christian combes on l'a dit il faudra
essayer de comprendre ça fait très
longtemps et on le sait tous collés les
uns les cas passer des services de
renseignement même intérieurs sont
faibles et donc il faudra aller
remuscler mais ça c'est un débat qu'on
va pas voir maintenant après attention
ne pas tout mélanger j'entends les
commentaires
il ya débat sur les questions de
sécurité on arrive on aura six aux
quartiers aucun ne tarissent voyez
maintenant aller la question migratoire
oui mais je pense qu'il faut pas tout
mélanger
oui je crois pas qu'il faille tout cas
tenace la france a soumise dit s'il est
avéré qu'il ya parmi les mises en cause
des demandeurs d'asile des réfugiés
clairement ils n'ont rien à faire en
france il n'y a pas qu'à droite que ce
débat est abordée ne faut pas tout en
cas de fatma houari
le fait que effectivement des gens qui
demandent l'asile dans notre pays et qui
se livre depuis ce livre est parce qu il
faut les interpeller à ce type d'actes
ne peuvent pas rester sur les eaux
internationales
nous sommes d'accord je réagissait aux
propos du président
elia qui disait je vais faire une
nouvelle loi taillé au voilà c'est ça
que je réagissais eh bien on va tout de
suite rejoindrait bien alexandre poussin
salle des conférences à nouveau sur ce
même sujet car vous êtes avec claude
malhuret
le président du groupe les indépendants
au sénat effectivement avec claude
malhuret d'abord un constat sur cette
flambée de violence à dijon est ce qu'il
ya eu et bien une faille des forces de
l'ordre alors que et bien par exemple le
maire de dijon françois rebsamen
témoigne en disant que les élus eux
mêmes ont découvert l'arrivée de cette
communauté tchétchène dans leur ville de
dijon
oui moi ce que je dénonce ce ne sont pas
ses insuffisances
ce que je dénonce comme d'ailleurs à mon
avis tous les français c'est qu'après
les émeutes qu'après les incendies de
voitures après les agressions des forces
de sécurité après les trafics de drogue
on vient d'assister à quelque chose
qu'on n'aurait jamais pu envisager en
france la guerre des gangs à la
kalachnikov dans les rues de dijon
c'est quand même ça qu'il faut dénoncer
c'est ça dont les français ont peur
c'est de ces violences là et pas des
violences de la police c'est pour ça que
la campagne actuelle contre les forces
de l'ordre est particulièrement malvenu
c'est une campagne qui est menée par des
gens qui se prétendent antiracistes et
qui lui disent qu'il l'amène au nom de
l'antiracisme
alors que leurs objectifs et leur
idéologie c'est exactement le contraire
ce sont des identitaires racialiste
qu'ils veulent et qui prône une france
communautariser ethniciser divisée
ségrégué et par conséquent c'est ça
qu'il faut dénoncer aujourd'hui bien
entendu j'entends qu'il faut pas faire
d'amalgamé il n'en reste pas moins que
ce sont les mêmes qui mène la campagne
quand on les forces de police et qui
l'amène au nom d'un intérêt 6 me
complète mandé voyez donc cela
évidemment il faut le dénoncer
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que les français
aujourd'hui constate ils ne sont pas
leurs forces de police ce n'est pas leur
la violence des forces de police qu'ils
craignent c'est la violence de ceux qui
s'attaquent aux forces de l'ordre et qui
s'attaque à l'unité de la république
parce que c'est l'unité de la république
est en cause le président de la
république disait ce sont des
séparatistes il faut dire le mot oui ce
sont des séparatistes et qui s'oppose à
l'unité de la république française et
qu'est ce que fait le gouvernement pour
lutter contre ce séparatisme et le
communautarisme je pense que la première
chose à faire c'est d'abord de punir
efficacement on nous dit qu'on va être
ferme
j'entends mais pour le moment je n'ai
pas encore vu les conséquences de cette
fermeté donc bien entendu j'espère qu'on
va retrouver ceux qui se baladent en
france avec des kalachnikov qui se
battent dans d'être dans une des scènes
de guérilla urbaine et que s'ils sont
tchétchènes ou d'autres nationalités
on va d'abord les sanctionner et ensuite
les expulser bien sûr et justement vous
parliez d'expulsion est ce qu'il faut et
bien réformer le régime du droit d'asile
comme le propose le président du groupe
l'est républicain bruno retailleau en
durcissant et bien le régime de
sanctions et d'expulsion pour les
réfugiés jeu il est évident que
quelqu'un qui arrive de l'étranger qui
demandent l'asile en france et qui se
livrent à ce genre
d'acte ne peut pas rester dans notre
pays il faut d'abord qu'il soit
sanctionné dans notre pays et qu'ensuite
il le quitte bien entendu ce n'est pas
sur ta mais pour moi l'essentiel n'est
pas là l'essentiel c'est pas seulement
celui du problème d'étrangers qui
viennent en france
l'essentiel c'est celui qui est en train
de se répandre d'une idéologie qui est
aujourd'hui on le voit bien dans les
manifestations exercées par des français
et des gens qui sont nés en france ou
qui sont en france depuis longtemps et
qui sont naturalisés pour certains mais
la plupart sont nés en france et sont
français et qu'ils sont en train de
prôner une division du pays
une une ethnisation du pays et ça ça
n'est pas seulement aux forces de police
à n'est pas seulement à la répression
c'est un problème c'est un débat
idéologique c'est un débat politique
c'est un débat philosophique sur lequel
il faut arrêtez arrêtez de céder à ceux
qui nous prône la repentance à ce qui
nous prouve la culpabilité la repentance
à la culpabilité aujourd'hui ça suffit
et les d'éboulement de la statue de
victor schoelcher autant si un anti
esclavagiste ça suffit de supporter ça
merci beaucoup
claude malhuret et plusieurs aspects
dans ce débat très complexe sur le
respect de l'autorité de l'état et de
l'ordre républicain
oui effectivement c'est au moins une
interview deux en inde qu'il y avait
quand même des sujets assez distincts
entre bien d'une part ces violences à
dijon et puis ce dont on a parlé un peu
plus vaste naturellement ce sur quoi est
venu claude malhuret
eh bien les divisions dans le pays avec
et bien ces différentes manifestations
manifestation antiraciste qui qu'il y
avait eu une manifestation aussi anti
police qu'est-ce que vous inspire ce
mouvement christian cambon ce contexte
dans lequel est bien on voudrait revenir
maintenant écoutez moi je réprouve
totalement les manifestations contre la
police la police la gendarmerie les
pompiers puisque la violence frappe
aussi les pompiers ce sont des corps
tout à fait estimable
quand on reprend l'actualité il ya plus
d'un an quand on voit ce qu'ils ont
encaissées entre les manifestations de
gilet jaune
là toutes les manifestations qui ont eu
lieu encore récemment
je crois que il faut véritablement faire
très attention parce que ancré dans
l'opinion publique
un état d'esprit qui commencent à faire
douter de la seule ici de la solidité de
ces corps de police qui défendent la
république et ceux des témoignages y
compris à l'intérieur de la police sur
certains problèmes mais kelly mais qu'il
y ait des problèmes qu'il y ait même des
comportements individuels qu'il y ait eu
des choses qu'on a dans ce cas là il y à
des dispositifs il y à des sanctions il
y a des rêves et je crois que la police
et ça c'est les statistiques sont
formelles à ce sujet démontrent que
c'est puni contrairement à ce qui est
raconté
mais je pense qu'il ne faut pas
déstabiliser comme le ministre de
l'intérieur l'a fait l'autre jour en
disant parfois l'émotion peut dépasser
l'application de la loi mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire les manifestations
wallace et ce sont ces propos la laisse
à croire que finalement tous ces gens là
peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent dans la
rue or les français ont peur et les
français refusent cette situation
qu'est-ce que vous inspirent ces
manifestations et puis la réaction
notamment du ministre de l'intérieur
at-il correctement géré pour vous cette
crise cette situation
smith de l'intérieur c'est pas une
surprise bien ça fait deux ou trois ans
que chaque chaque fois il est pointé
comme le maillon faible ou pas je veux
pas l'accabler il qu'après il ya
plusieurs sujets sur les manifestations
sur la question de la police et des
fonctionnaires en général moi je
soutiens les forces de sécurité notre
pays parce que le sait le travail
qu'elles font au quotidien ces hommes et
ces femmes qui passent des jours parfois
au péril de leur vie que c'était reste
il faut les soutenir
je crois que c'est important de le dire
ils sont allés manifester je vais juste
terminer mon propos je verrai je vais
terminer sur ça après donc il faut être
comme partout il faut être extrêmement
dur quand il ya des vins des dérives
personnelles soit par des violences
soient des propos racistes et là il faut
les sanctionner
et pas comme audi de ministres castaner
sur une présentation ils ont ils ont
droit
ce sont des justiciables comme les
autres donc ça c'est le premier point
sur la police sur le deuxième point sur
l'oral si c'est pas la même chose
on peut être contre le racisme n'est pas
forcément contre la police à la voix
contre le racisme on peut aussi dire que
notre pays il y à du racisme
je ne dis pas que du racisme d'état ni
systématique c'est pas bon c'est pas ce
que je dis je le dis qu'il ya je
rappelle que dans les vingt dernières
années
un parti d'extrême droite arrive au
second tour d'élection présidentielle il
ya du racisme
moi qui m'appelle rachid je pourrais
vous en parler des heures je le vis au
quotidien
mais dans la fin seul dans les autres
corps pour vous ou bien plus
particulièrement dans la police comme
très stimulant je ne fais pas les
manifestants que vous voyez dans la rue
quand toute la jeunesse descend au point
de grande partie à jeunesse descend on
peut s'interroger la jeunesse quand elle
descend soit ici aux etats unis elle
descend contre le racisme pas contre la
police à son attention nous mêmes en
tant que responsable politique ou médias
à ne pas opposer une jeunesse et la
police ce n'est pas vrai et moi je me
bats pour cela il faut être républicain
les français qui étaient joue un rôle
essentiel je rappelle qu'on est encore
dans une phase où il ya du terrorisme ça
et on voit le travail qu'elles font mais
il faut aussi dure sur la question du
racisme et donc je pense que c'est ça le
débat et ça n'a rien à voir avec ce que
j'entends depuis ta leur sueur du
racialisme je ne sais quoi
moi je soutiens les manifestions pour
contre le racisme pour autant je
respecte l'histoire de mon pays et je
sais que si on prend jules ferry il ya
du dol excellent puisqu'il a fait
l'école laïque et gratuite pour tous et
je sais qu'à du moins bien sûr la
question la cotisation
il faut qu'on soit capable de regarder
notre histoire dans les yeux qu'elle
soit partagée sans aller plus loin voilà
moi ce que je veux dire c'est un scoop
pour vous parler de notre histoire
justement il ya eu un moment très fort
lors de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement ce moment
des changes entre max brisson et edouard
philippe justement sur notre histoire
notre histoire glorieuse compliqué et
avec sa part d'ombré pour reprendre les
mots du premier ministre on propose de
réécouter ce mois et on en parle tout
petit en plateau et vous vous assurez
que l'on continuera à écrire et
enseigner l'histoire de france non sous
la dictature d'une pensée militante
largement communautariste mais avec
l'esprit civique technique et la
recherche de l'universalisme qui
caractérise l héritage des lumières
peut-on me désigner une période de
l'histoire un homme ou une femme qui
ayant fait quelque chose
serais tu de toute évidence et dans tous
les aspects lumineux et n'aurait pas sa
part d'ombré
sérieusement je sens que senna on me dit
il y à gérard larcher
je
[Musique]
je crains monsieur le président que même
vous plus sérieusement avant moi il ya
eu l'abbé grégoire ici monsieur le
président monsieur le président même lui
ah oui même si on l'avait grégoire il ya
des choses à dire comme quoi on peut
s'ouvrir sur des thèmes graves notamment
celui de regarder notre histoire en
phase avec ses failles avec cette
complexité
christian cambon mais c'est à dire qu'il
faut surtout cesser de la regarder à
travers la grille de lecture que le delà
du jour d'aujourd'hui la grille des
lecteurs contemporaine contemporaine il
est évident que une histoire elle se
prend dans sa totalité
parce que si on commence à faire le tri
entre les bons comportements et les
mauvais on prend le colonialisme il ya
eu des pages sombres du colonialisme à
l'évidence
et puis il ya eu aussi des français des
français comptent accepté de s'expatrier
et qui ont fait les instituts pasteur en
asie en afrique il ya des gens qui ont
enseigné à des jeunes de ses colonies et
qu'on fait un travail extraordinaire
il faut tout prendre globalement et puis
après rien n'empêche aux historiens
moi je préfère laisser les historiens
travailler sur ces périodes plutôt que
pour essayer de de créer des mots
d'ordre et de mobiliser des masses on
vienne déboulonner des statuts et lancer
des mots d'or je pense qu'effectivement
notre histoire on peut en être fier il
ya pas beaucoup de pays qu une histoire
comme l'histoire de france 1
et donc je pense que il faut être plutôt
prudent et faire attention de ne pas se
servir des figures qui ont agi en
fonction de l'état d'esprit du moment
qu'il n'était évidemment pas celui
d'aujourd'hui
earache était mal moi je pense
qu'effectivement c'est le travail des
historiens mais je faisais un exemple
l'effet que l'histoire de france allait
s' il ya le génie français il ya des
sons ou des pages plus sombre il faut
totalement si je reprends par exemple en
un des premiers gestes du président
hollande c'est de disposer notamment aux
de rendre hommage à jules ferry genève
au catalogue il a évoqué les deux
aspects je vous donne un exemple qui
mérite que il ya un travail
si vous prenez l'histoire de la
collaboration en france le plus grand
historien spécialiste il s'appelle
paxton ni l'américain ni l'état français
donc je pense qu'un travail d'historien
faire sur tout ce qu'on a fait et puis
voilà sur la cotisation moi je dis par
essence à les mauvaises par essence
après on peut avoir des débats mais je
là c'est que il faut regarder et moi
plutôt que des bruits des statuts je
pense que des boutons en rajouter
certains il ya des personnages d'autres
histoires qui ne sont pas assez mis en
valeur qui je pense ne peuvent être
aussi des exemples des modèles pour la
jeunesse d'aujourd'hui
faisons ce travail là mais je pense que
c'est plutôt aux historiens qu'il faut
donner ce travail-là de nous faire
avancer dans l'enseignement
je crois qu'il ya encore des trous dans
l'enseignement à l'école sur l'histoire
s il ya un problème d'enseignement de
l'histoire quand on voit non mais quand
on voit effectivement et bien ces
personnes qui déboulonne ses statuts et
dans le jeu donne un exemple concret sur
la guerre d'algérie
oui c'est à la fois un impensé
conséquent notre pays est quasiment pas
étudié dans les classes nationale et je
pense que pour le coup c'est une période
qu'il faudrait mieux travailler et mieux
présenter aux français
alès qui a été bien moins bien moi je
viens d'une famille qu'il en algérie je
connais un peu l'histoire et je vois là
donc je peux vous en raconter les c'est
pas ça le débat
je crois qu'il a besoin aujourd'hui
encore une fois de d'avoir ce travail
sur l'histoire indistinct une un travail
apaiser un travail contradictoires et
surtout avec une idée c'est de
rassembler les français parce que on
parle aujourd'hui
mais il ya un siècle quand il y avait
une immigration à l'époque polonaise ou
italiennes faut lire ce qui est écrit à
l'époque où ce qui était fait ouais on
peut utiliser l'histoire pour dire à la
fin on peut se rassembler on peut faire
corps et unité je crois que ça qu'il
faut rappeler nôtres la devise d'autres
pays c'est important et je crois que
c'est vers ça qu'il faut avancer on a
parlé de l'histoire on va aussi parler
de l'avenir l'avenir et bien c'est la
question des jeunes il en a été aussi
beaucoup question lors de cette séance
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
alexandre vous êtes justement avec
patrick kanner pour revenir et bien sur
ce sujet effectivement entame un sujet
inquiétant puisque à la rentrée de
septembre
sept cent mille jeunes vont arriver sur
le marché du travail beaucoup pourraient
rester au chômage patrick kanner et ce
qu'il y a le risque d'avoir une
génération sacrifiée avec cette crise
économique nous avons devant nous un
défi social majeur sociale surprend du
chômage me rappelle qu' on sera au moins
un million d'emplois détruits à cause de
la crise ducobu de 19
premièrement deuxièmement vient se
rajouter l'arrivée de 700000 aux moins
jeunes sur marché du travail en
septembre et donc notre responsabilité
c'est non seulement d'assurer un minimum
de ressources y compris pour des jeunes
qui sont aujourd'hui en rupture
il yal et la question du revenu de base
se pose il faudra la pause est très
clairement en tout cas nous nous la
posons en tant que sénateur socialiste
au gouvernement qui a fait des gestes en
direction des étudiants par exemple mais
qui sont très largement insuffisant et
il faudra aussi s'interroger sur des
solutions alternatives chômage des
jeunes n'est pas supportable pour une
autre société est donc relancé les
emplois aidés relancé le service civique
à mener finalement un état providence en
direction des jeunes même pour un temps
compté sera absolument nécessaire sinon
nous aurons une énorme crise sociale
devant nous est portée par des jeunes en
désespérance donc l'une des propositions
socialistes pour éviter ce chômage des
jeunes est bien ce serait de vraiment
mettre en place ce revenu de base qui
avait notamment été portée par benoît
hamon pendant la présidentielle alors
vraiment apporté ce qu'on appelle revenu
minimum d'existence l'onu de base est en
fait un alliage de différentes
ressources qui peuvent être rassemblés
pour permettre un minimum de survie
permettez moi l'expression
et ce sont une vingtaine de départements
socialistes qui ont cette idée nous
l'avons toujours portés dans les lois
d'urgence toujours refusée par le
gouvernement et la majorité de droite du
sénat je le regrette très très
simplement donc ce revenu de base
peut-être une solution intéressante
certains l'appellent le rsa pour les
jeunes de moins de 25 ans je pense que
l'avenir d'un jeune n'est pas d'avoir le
rsa mais par contre que nous puissions
assurer ce minimum de survie pour des
jeunes qui sera en grande difficulté
ce sera l'honneur de la république alors
les solutions sur lesquelles planche le
gouvernement sont plutôt différente
le gouvernement hésite entre une prime à
l'embauché pour les jeunes ou alors une
baisse de charges sur les contrats
jeunes ce ne sera pas suffisant selon
vous savez on prendra tout ce qui
viendra et qui pourra aller dans le bon
sens et nous les analyserons ces
promotions du gouvernement simplement ce
que nous voulons c'est les solutions de
masse que le problème sera un problème
de masse
on n'est pas sur 10000 20000 trente
mille jeunes vous l'avait révélé
chiffres plus de 700 mille jeunes qui
arrivent sur le marché de l'emploi
en tout cas nous ne contribueront par
nos propositions avoir une solution
d'urgence globale pour l'ensemble de
cette génération qui va être
effectivement la première victime de la
crise sociale qui nous attend merci
beaucoup patrick kanner d'avoir répondu
à mes questions c'est évidemment les
ouïes sept cent mille jeunes vont être
en difficulté entrent sur le marché du
travail
christian cambon
les élèves eux plutôt un allègement des
charges pour l'emploi des jeunes
mais est ce vraiment le problème puisque
les charges pour les entreprises sont
déjà faibles sur ses employeurs n
écouter ce qui compte
effectivement c'est que les jeunes qui
vont arriver dans une situation
excessivement tendu excessivement
difficile puisse le plus possible
bénéficier de toutes les chances qui
leur permettra d'intégrer le monde du
travail et notre société donc
effectivement cela ne passe absolument
pas contrairement à ce qu évoquer nos
collègues communistes dans la séance par
une diminution du temps de travail
nous sommes un certain nombre à voyager
de par le monde je peux vous dire que
franchement c'est pas la priorité des
gens de moins travailler
bien au contraire en ce qui concerne ces
jeunes je pense qu'il faut les aider à
trouver leur place dans le milieu des
entreprises
moi j'ai piloté l'apprentissage dans
cette région d'île de france pendant 12
ans je sais qu actuellement le problème
des jeunes apprentis c'est de trouver un
maître d'apprentissage donc une
entreprise qui est capable de consacrer
et j'en ai un peu de temps lancé par le
gouvernement
oui bien sûr remettre de sa blessure il
faut y aller il faut y aller parce que
rien n'est pire que l'échec scolaire et
donc l'apprentissage est une voie
formidable un véritable passeport pour
l'emploi
il faut donc aider ces jeunes à trouver
des stages nous nous sommes débordés par
des demandes dans nos départements
on nous dit retrouvez-nous un stage
trouver une entreprise donc je crois que
ça c'est la base
il faut leur donner de l'espoir sinon
effectivement on les retrouvera dans les
rues avec des mots de contestation qui
ne sont pas souhaitables pour une
génération qui en plus va devoir payer
400 milliards de dettes que nous sommes
en train de nous mettre sur le dos
gratuité mal à ce que le gouvernement
prend le sujet par le bon bout est ce
que vous craignez une génération
convient d'une génération sacrifiée pour
ces sept cent mille jeunes
d'abord je vais dire que le gouvernement
découvre enfin la jeunesse parce que il
est là depuis trois ans la seule mesure
phare pour la jeunesse c'est un ses nus
on parlera des débats sur le salut mais
c'est quand même pas vers celle s'était
pas franchement quelque chose vers
l'emploi bon il faut le dire qui coûte
quand même un peu d'argent donc là moi
je pense comme l'a dit patrick anr je
pense qu'à part une mesure écrit son
roman la nuit ils font ce qu il y aura
comme un piano plusieurs mesures parce
que il ya des situations effectivement
ce sera de l'apprentissage l'autre créé
d'emplois mais à la fin la cada qui
parle beaucoup du revenu de battre on
n'est donc pas un mec c'est moi alors
moi j'ai moi je suis plutôt enclin à
parler dotation
capital de nancy passion qui est dans
notre dispositif notamment je vous
invite à l'érable revenu de base
en tout cas je pense que c'est un
élément qui ne vont pas forcément à
toutes les situations et donc je vous
invite à lire d'ailleurs les travaux de
guillaume mathelier qui travaillent ces
questions là après je pense que la
question c'est la crise économico non
vie mais la création d'emplois parce que
on peut tout discuter la question
d'emploi et je trouve qu'au gouvernement
quand il dit il va abaisser il va faire
des prime jeunesse c'est du déjà vu ça
du déjà vu on a déjà vu ça à plusieurs
reprises le dire les déprime donc la
question globale sait aujourd'hui
comment il relance l'emploi d'autres
pays et moi je lui demanderais d'abord
de commencer par revenir sur
l'allocation chômage sa réforme parce
que sa réforme qui a été mis en place
je rappelle que pour les jeunes ld
réduit d'autant leur capacité à être
indemnisées rapidement et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut trouver de
l'emploi pour les uns mais aussi pouvoir
survivre parce que dans un son de
départements aujourd'hui financièrement
ça devient très compliqué pour les gens
mais qu'est ce que vous pensez du débat
sur le rsa jeunes que qu'on voit naître
dans le gouvernement
enfin dans la majorité gouvernementale
avec d'une part stanislas guerre inique
mais cette proposition pour sortir de la
crise et pion l'entente est bien le
gouvernement qui est beaucoup moins
favorable au témoin d'une manière
générale dans les moments que nous
vivons je suis globalement contre ces
espèces de gadgets que l'on va sortir
soudés on en a vus sous tous les
gouvernements
ça n'a jamais marché tout d'un filet de
sécurité exceptionnelles pour sa beauté
particulière je pense que la leur donner
la possibilité de se former
que ce soit dans l'enseignement général
dans l'enseignement technique vous par
le biais de l'apprentissage leur donner
la possibilité de récupérer en aidant
les entreprises qui les accueillent des
contrats pour démarrer à l'emploi qu'est
ce qui compte c'est de mettre le pied à
l'étrier à ces jeunes c'est de montrer
ce dont ils sont capables
c'est pas systématiquement de leur dire
voilà pour vous et bien sûr qu'il faut
les aider bien sûr qu'il faut que par
exemple les banques que soit un tout
petit peu plus souple sur l'octroi des
prêts étudiants ou des prêts de
formation parce que véritablement on a
un vrai problème en france de ce côté là
je crois que ça ce sont des mesures
concrètes qu'attendent les gens c'est
pas un nouveau dispositif qui dans trois
ans aura donné satisfaction à dix mille
jeunes par rapport à la situation que
l'on connaît franchement on est en
dehors du coup je pense que ce qu'il
faut c'est effectivement leur donner la
possibilité
il ya des systèmes qui fonctionnent déjà
vous avez des bourses pour les jeunes
qui sont en qui continuent d études ou
des formations on peut aller beaucoup
plus loin on peut aller beaucoup plus
loin dans le logement des jeunes pour
les aider parce que ça coûte quand même
très cher dans nos métropoles de se
loger
ça ce sont des sujets qui existe une
revalorisation des apl peut-être une
revalorisation des apl parce que là il
ya un véritable problème de logement
mais je pense qu'il faut arrêter de
sortir des mesures gadgets dont le temps
qui sera nécessaire pour les mettre en
route fait que ça les condamne avant le
mot de la fin ça a basculé sur lesquels
vous avez d'accord les appels pour le
court non non d'accord mais vraiment les
abaisser moi je pense que déjà je pense
qu'il pourrait aussi entendre via les
états généraux ce qui vaut de la
jeunesse puisque il ya aussi une
jeunesse à écouter qui dans sa diversité
et après sur monsieur guérini j'espère
que c'est pas un concours lépine pour
sauver sa tête
après des municipales aussi
catastrophique pour les roms voilà le
retour de la politique merci beaucoup au
rachis tu t'es mal c'est bientôt la
formation d'un gouvernement alors y'en
avait sûrement de leur carte
la bomba salue la formation du
gouvernement on en reparlera
certainement merci beaucoup
christian cambon d'avoir participé à ce
débat c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi à 18
heures vous avez rendez vous avec
rebecca fitoussi et son émission allons
plus loin elle reviendra notamment avec
ses invités sur les événements de dijon
très bonne soirée sur public sénat et à
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]